on passait
chaise.com/h evenscool tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentiels
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chains.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue Fatou qui va
m'accompagner pour cette sixième ronde
du Nord-Ouest
et salut à tous merci pour cette accueil
ici sur la chaîne
donc on a de belles parties aujourd'hui
on passe en perspective Fatou avec déjà
un combat 100% norvégien
cette première ronde avec Ariane Tarik
elle est blanc contre Marius Carlson
donc Ariane qui est pour l'instant en
dernier au classement dernier classement
et qui est le joueur on va dire local
qui a été invité mais qui est un peu le
moins fort du tournoi c'est le petit
poucet
il aura beaucoup à faire un contrat
manus 45 qui est qui est pas hyper en
forme dans ce tournoi d'ailleurs mais il
y a pas encore gagné une seule partie
Magnus qui vient d'une sicilienne pour
essayer de de jouer à un jeu un peu
dynamique et essayer de d'avoir
l'avantage contre contre Paris donc pour
l'instant bah écoute c'est rien de se
passe enfin rien ne
n'est
incroyable c'est une blague
qui joue le répertoire de stouf
alors attends je vais ouvrir un petit
peu le chat parce que moi j'ai pas du
tout encore ouvert les chats
j'espère pour lui qui nous souhaite pour
gagner ah ouais parce que si il joue
comme moi il a peut-être une chance de
faire la scène sinon ça va être
difficile
en tout cas on lui souhaite et salut thé
vert
salut thé vert thé vert qui vient
apprendre un petit peu des meilleurs sur
justcom FR faites comme lui les gens
alors attendez j'installe mes petites
chattes là pour pouvoir vous lire ce qui
paraît que je lis beaucoup alors vous
lire sur sur twitch et aussi sur Youtube
j'ai tout ouvert
donc je vais être prêt dans un instant
et on a récupéré tout ça
et moi je suis dans quelques heures thé
vert
la finale d'option c'est pas pour tout
de suite exactement
tu peux rester
on va essayer quand même de parler de
structure depuis
la jeté
à la mode
souvent ici à la place un prochain mon
micro
salut Irun CB
souvent la place de des quatre et voilà
on aime bien jouer petit rock ici et sur
A6 il y a plein de coupes aussi on peut
je fous prends des sets suivi
de D4 et d'un point de 4 parce que
n'est plus là on peut plus venir ça
venir m'attaquer madame et
on aime bien ça dans les
débutants
il faut prendre le centre c'est hyper
important mettre les pions au milieu des
principes d'ouverture c'est ça donc même
si vous connaissez pas le jeu d'Arthur
essayez d'appliquer ça
[Musique]
le bruit où c'est chez moi
je pense que tout le monde a entendu
ouvert je comprenais pas
et
donc voilà sinon on peut jouer à la
place de ça on joue des trois qui a un
coup très intéressant qui a l'air
bizarre tous les trois ans c'est pas un
coup de développement ouais généralement
on pousse les pions quand on vous a
montré et pour sortir des fous etc mais
l'idée de faire fruité 3 c'est de garder
le foot surtout pas échanger et avec
comme finalité de le mettre en C2 pour
jouer de 4 et on a plein de pollutions
qui sont similaires après à des
Espagnols
ou le fouet est parti là-bas et en fait
le revenu par ici ça transpose en
demande de l'espagnol donc c'est
intéressant mais ici tari il a pas du
tout voulu faire ça il a fait des cartes
directement ce qui est un coup hyper
intéressant parce que
elle va les prendre merci
généralement on fait
danser que le cavalier puisse pas faire
cavaler ses 6 en fait
mais là il me fait mentir ce qui vient
de prendre des quatre
car elle va aller prendre
est-ce que ça change énormément
ton cadeau va aussi avoir pas mal
d'influence au centre
alors
il peut pas trop 5 ça c'est moche pour
l'instant ça a laissé ce pion arrière en
D6 c'est la case en dessin qui a fait
belle pour les blancs on pourra
contrôler mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des
positions beaucoup de position dans
laquelle et ben tu joues pour 5 et tu as
besoin en fait que tes pièces contrôlent
ces cas-là
c'est pour ça que ton cavalent de cartes
et contrôle pas la carte de 5 c'est ce
qui me gêne un petit peu ici c'est vrai
pas mal mais bon c'est la théorie donc
la Caval est prendre des cartes c'est je
pense une quasi nouveauté je vais
regarder si ça a déjà été joué oui alors
oui bien sûr j'ai la base j'ai la base
pour cheesecom il y a 77 parties c'est
pas énorme si je prends un coup avant
d'un point d'écart voilà d'un point de 4
a été joué à 1860 fois sur la base sur
la base de données de chia scam contre
34 fois qu'elle va les prendre les
quatre
ce qui annonce quand même la nouveauté
quoi
tu vois c'est c'est une nouveauté c'est
quelque chose que tu arrives à regarder
c'est une évidence parce que toujours
pas ça quasiment tempo
sachant que bon vu son niveau il sait
que le groupe c'est quand même d'un
point de 4 se préparer c'est préparé
donc il a une ligne après ça va pas être
un truc non plus qui doit être
c'est pas la variante qui a l'air très
dangereuse donc faut juste vos échecs
quoi donc voilà et salut à tous ceux qui
arrivent on a vu un malin qui arrive sur
le chat on a eu Titi de ciel bleu
Dav du 56 et maintenant maître Robin
bienvenue à tous monsieur côté
[Musique]
et car elle est prend des quatre donc ok
bah écoute on va voir un signe
sicilienne c'est un peu bizarre parce
que généralement quand on a ces idées
enfin cette plan avec ce schéma
on joue plutôt des fous 3 F3 ou truc
comme ça ce qu'on appelle l'attaque
anglaise mais le fou va très rarement en
B5 en fait c'est pollution le faux C4 en
E2 en D3 ou en G2 des fois mettre le
four en B5 dans une scène ouverte tu
vois jamais
tu le vois jamais
donc bon écoutez c'est intéressant à
voir peut-être que
tout ça Magnus qui réfléchit Magnus qui
a qui a pas dû
enfin je pense pas qu'il soit vraiment
dans ces connaissances théorique tu vois
c'est bizarre quand même ça fait oui tu
arrives salut Eddy
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir
on vient de voir un Magnus
est-ce que tu veux alors on a d'autres
parties sur toutes là on a goût cash
Anish on a fini
qui est notre petit français aussi hop
voir si j'ai bien fait des trucs donc
elle est blanc
c'est un gros derby les gens qui sont
beaucoup jaunes online
et donc c'est intéressant en tout cas de
de les voir
c'est une position assez marrante parce
que
en fait j'en ai parlé hier avec Yoshua
d'ailleurs c'est marrant
cette position
parce qu'on a eu des positions hier on a
eu une Rossolimo ça entière je sais plus
et en fait on avait dit que dépend et la
vente la plus jouée et que betran c'est
une ligne qui est qui a eu bon on va
dire ce moment de mode mais qui
maintenant et Ben et ben bon il reste
toujours hein mais c'est un peu
populaire je pense que des prends
et contre B prend et ben on fait le tour
pour en fait se garder l'idée de faire
ces trois à quatre comme tout à l'heure
on va essayer de prendre le centre comme
on avait dit
mais des fois on peut même jouer sur
cavalier 5
pour en fait mettre tous les pions
ça dépend du mec tous les pions au
centre
et ça c'est des ouvertures qui existent
etc
et donc torrent c'est le coup c'est le
coup normal ici on joue pas ces trois
directs
on va devoir rejet C4 et en fait on perd
un temps d'avoir juste ces trois puis
c'est quatre
donc commence par tour mais du coup sur
sur ça il a joué
dames et 7 cavalier A3 et canal à 3 pour
moi
c'est une nouveauté
donc bon après je sais pas un
spécialiste
mais c'est pas possible
est-ce que tu avais déjà eu pas tout toi
ce coup c'est bizarre
on vous dit de mettre les cavaliers
au centre
cavalier au bord cavalier mort
et qui avait le milieu cavalier
heureux très bien merci donc moi j'avais
deux trucs deux phrases pour ça c'était
quand même au milieu qui a valu heureux
ou qui avait le milieu c'est mieux bon
en tout casier vers le centre d'accord
donc Cavalera 3 c'est un coup bizarre
mais j'ai des idées plus tard de venir
en C4 et de contrôler des cadres
importantes dans la russellium
très souvent ça se joue là-dessus par
exemple ici même E5 est un coup qu'on
peut regarder ça empêche qu'elle est F6
ça contrône un petit peu les pions du
centre
bon je pense que si c'est bon pour la
noir pour essayer d'éliminer le pion
central et plus tard d'essayer de mettre
les pions au centre mais mais sans que
ça a toujours dans la ressourdiment un
peu son intérêt et donc avait la 3 on
voit qu'il veut venir vers 5 donc ça ça
paraît logique mais c'est un coup que je
ne connais pas je vais mettre à la base
de données juste pour voir je suis
curieux
pas partie quoi
justement vraiment savoir où tu vas le
mettre si tu vas réussir à avoir à le
mettre en C4 comment
[Musique]
le centre
j'ai la grosse question
ça paraît bizarre donc là on vous dit
des pièces au centre on voit les trucs
qui mettent des cavaliers au bord
donc une fois vraiment tir mais les
Noirs c'est normal votre cavaliers en H6
parce que comme on a dit avant sur
cavalier 5 qui embêtant et en fait on va
aller très loin et des quatre et le
Cavalaire fait le tour du monde et au
final derrière il n'a pas forcément de
très bonne cadre en B6
et donc le Caval il va plutôt en H6 pour
pas se faire attaquer et en fait plus
tard mon plan inclure ça va être petit
rock F6 cavalier F7 c'est un plan assez
bizarre mais c'est assez standard
donc par contre c'est du coup qui avait
l'air à 3 qui m'interroge un peu plus
donc si on suit le raisonnement de firou
l'astre
ce qui se passe
des cinq ça n'a pas large génial parce
que je vous retrouve la position
je pense pas que ça fasse ça
parfois si je sais pas ce que ce que je
fais c'est une bonne question
non mais en fait souvent dans ces
pollutions
doubler certes mais la colonne D peut
être faible et ce qui joue un coup plus
tard comme DC ça a toujours des rupture
avec E5 sur le long terme avec la
structure qui va un peu exploser et la
catastin qu'il est dur à prendre pour
les Noirs donc ces structures assez
intéressante souvent tu peux manger
souvent tu manges pas et il y a aussi un
une idée intéressante bon qui n'arrivera
pas mais si je fais c'est les majorites
à faire le 5 je peux aussi me laisser
des idées comme cavalier des 6
regarde
bon
ok un jour quoi si rock pas il y a un
problème mais c'est assez joli de voir
ce thème échec il prend je fais échec a
découvertes et je mange la dame bon ça
n'arrivera pas bien sûr mais avec le 5
on voit bien qu'il y a des idées en
relation avec ça quoi
donc voilà si je rejaoui il reprend sa
deuxième place au Ranc oui alors j'ai
regardé on a vu que Naka est passé
numéro 2 mondial après la partie d'hier
après la défaite de Caravana contre ma
mère et donc après j'ai vu que le numéro
2 3 4 se joue à la virgule près je crois
là je peux te dire si tu veux les hello
exactes des des gens en direct attends
virtuellement au Magnus il est trop
devant et il a 50 points 60 points
d'avance même si il en perd plein ici
voilà elle met du Rohff il a 20 pardon
numéro 2 c'est Nakamura 27 27 83,5
numéro 3 c'est Firo
27,83,2
quatrième c'est karwana 27 82,4 ça se
voit rien et ensuite tu as Ding 80 un
époque 119 etc et donc en fait là ils
sont entre il y a un point entre le 2 et
le 4 quoi donc
le classement peut changer
dans cette partie et lorsqu'il est
marrant c'est que actuellement le numéro
de mondial c'est Nakamura et le numéro 3
mondial c'est firou
et donc les deux se jouent pour
éventuellement
une place enfin une deuxième place au
classement mondial pour l'instant donc
il y a un Sephiro gagne il passe 2e
c'est Naka gagne il reste devant
après
c'est ça se joue
pas grand chose quoi
il y a même pas un point d'écart
bonjour
oui je suis d'accord Caraïbes dans le
dans l'ouverture généralement on va tout
le temps bouger une pièce à la fois
jusqu'à prendre le centre etc mais il y
a des cas exceptionnels
et surtout il y a des l'écran joueurs
savent à quel moment ils peuvent faire
cette lion
il faut voir aussi qu'on a position elle
est fermée c'est-à-dire qu'elle a pas
encore de tension au centre et ben on
peut se permettre de bouger deux fois la
même pièce parce que il y a pas
l'attaque on va dire qui peuvent arriver
vite le problème de bouger deux fois la
même pièce dans l'ouverture c'est que je
peux être en retard de développement
mais quand je suis en retard de
développement le problème c'est que je
peux me faire attaquer en fait mais si
la pollution est tranquille plate qui a
pas encore d'attaque et ben je peux voir
les choses arrivent
faut que tu vas la bouger plus
facilement si tu as des plans à long
terme ou tu vas avoir des ouvertures tu
construis assez lentement ou si tu te
fais attaquer mais sinon
on va éviter
en tout cas chez les débutants mieux
vaut éviter de reprendre la même pièce
dans l'ouverture
essayez de sortir vos pièces une à la
fois à prendre le centre mettre les
cavaliers vers le milieu les fous vers
le milieu mettre le rock enfin faire le
rock etc tout ça c'est important
j'ai pas le j'ai pas les prix
malheureusement ici j'ai pas les prix
alors je sais pas si peut-être le SMIC
ça a mis il nous a peut-être fait le
problème c'est que j'ai pas la scène
pour mettre les prix alors je sais plus
si je les ai peut-être que j'ai un
quelque part mais les prix sont énormes
je peux avoir je crois j'ai le site
j'accès aussi je pense que je peux vous
les donner un peu grosso modo prize
tournoi de ce niveau là les prix les
prix énorme alors oui donc les les
prix sont en
je sais pas comment ça s'appelle la
monnaie norvégienne je vois il y a
marqué
je pense que je pense que c'est comme
monnaie je connais pas la monnaie
norvégien mais si vous voulez si vous
voulez faire un petit peu faire
la traduction ou on a le premier prix
c'est 150 000 donc
voilà 4000
au 3e 200000 bref et même le dernier
tournoi il prend 120 000 noces donc 120
000 noces en euros je sais pas si vous
voulez nous les faire mais je pense que
c'est beaucoup
et généralement ce type de tournoi
les prix qu'on donne aux joueurs c'est
de l'ordre de 100.000 euros
105 ans au premier oui j'avais 100000
mais oui c'est à peu près ça
donc un autre 0085
12 notes OK
ouais bon vous voyez que 750 000 notes
c'est le premier prix et après même le
dernier c'est il prend il prend 120 000
donc c'est 120 000 notes enfin si un
euro ça fait 12 notes comment ça fait
Fatou 120 000 notes
je vais dire ta phrase je ne t'ai pas
écouté non mais 120
pour 12 c'est facile tu rajoutes 0
si 1 €, ça fait 12 notes
120 000 notes ça fait 10000 euros
ça fait 12 notes 10 euros ça fait 120 m
1000 euros ça fait 1200 noces 10.000
euros
bon bref c'est perdu mais
on est là dessus
bref
tu m'as appris à lire
moi je lis voilà
donc voilà en fait c'est les prix sont
énormes mais bon c'est les meilleurs
joueurs du monde et encore c'est les
prix sont énormes mais pas tant que ça
en fait si vous comparez ça à du foot
c'est des millions et des millions qui
brassent là on n'est pas dans les
millions aux échecs vous me direz que tu
gagnes un tournoi tu gagnes 105000 euros
en une semaine bah c'est pas mal hein
mais bon pour être le numéro 1 ou être
le meilleur joueur du monde de tous les
temps
en fait c'est pas beaucoup comparé à
d'autres choses comparé au tennis
comparé au foot comparé à d'autres
choses voilà après ça reste énorme mais
pour être le meilleur joueur du monde ok
si vous comparez Messi à ça je pense pas
que Messi va se déplacer pour 65000
euros quoi
voilà
bah oui
non mais nous on voit que c'est énorme
on voit que c'est énorme les prix mais
en fait si vous comparez si vous
comparez à d'autres à d'autres sports en
fait il y a pas d'argent déjà donc pour
bien vivre nos échec il faut être
je pense un bon top 100 mondial quoi
top 15 et 20 Ah oui non mais en fait les
joueurs qui vivent très très mal d'échec
c'est les joueurs qui sont qui sont
invités à cet endroit et il y en a une
vingtaine
entre eux
quand tu as 2710 tu es pas trop invité
dans comme ça
tu crois que tu arrives il est bien
content d'être là tu vois parce qu'il a
26 50 il est entouré du top 10 mondial
il fait un tournoi il y a pas mal
d'argent en jeu en plus il a il a
l'opportunité de pouvoir agir contre
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
super mais après il joue aussi parce
qu'il norvégien quoi et c'est un peu
normal d'ailleurs en tant que spamsover
et tout de vouloir aussi mettre un
norvégien dans son tournoi quoi
et donc c'est cool d'ailleurs moi
j'encourage ça faire venir un peu des
des champions nationaux dans leur
tournoi c'est cool
c'est un peu normal
payé évidemment en fait
il faut que vous sachiez que Carlsen par
exemple pour un tournoi comme ça il
prend 750
000 noces
pour jouer et enfin pour le premier prix
qui va gagner mais il y a les prix mais
qu'un scène pour qu'il vienne il faut le
payer en fait il faut savoir que les
joueurs ils ont
l'hôtel qui est payé mais l'hôtel c'est
pas le Formule 1 du coin c'est l'hôtel
ça va être
un autre enfin le meilleur hôtel de
l'endroit où ils vont être un truc de
ouf avec la bouffe etc et en plus de
tout ce qui est payé et ben chaque
joueur reçoit un cachet donc pour enfin
voilà
par en Cassen je pense que le premier
prix il a déjà gagné
tu vois je pense que tu donnes ce prix
là à 45 et en plus il peut gagner encore
un prix
je pense ah oui je suis sûr
généralement comme ça très souvent tu es
un cachet après je sais pas à quel point
les cachets sont importants mais je sais
par exemple que pour ce plat du monde de
glitter il prend un gros cas je sais pas
venir juste pour jouer
c'est quelque chose de tu vois et bon
maintenant il est plus champion du monde
mais bon
sans cacher je pense qu'il vient pas
après c'est un tournoi dans son pays
peut-être que là il y a un truc
différent peut-être que c'est différent
de manière générale après moi je sais
pas je lui ai pas par là mais ça me
parait normal en fait parce que si il
vient pour jouer gratuit entre
guillemets et bien il tue un peu le
marché quoi et c'est comme ça quoi tu
vois enfin je pense que c'est tous les
joueurs tous les joueurs voilà plein de
cachets non mais tu me tu me dis c'était
d'accord ou pas enfin tu vois même
Robinson je pense que c'est ça je pense
que les joueurs prennent des cachets
reçoivent de l'argent on va changer un
petit peu les mots
recevoir plus que ce qui est annoncé
comme prix moi je pense que je pense que
personne n'y prend le premier prix déjà
ouais c'est ça moi ça me paraît fou mais
c'est pas possible
tu as
enfin tu viens 10 jours
je me souviens que Dubaï le le pour que
il y a vu je sais pas du monde à Dubaï
de but c'est rapide et je crois que
c'était c'était
la j'ai entendu c'était la folie genre
il prenais trois fois
champion du monde mais tous les joueurs
reçoivent
regarde Tiger Woods gagné 1 million de
dollars comme prime mais bon après
encore une fois on est golf
tu vois s'il y a des il y a des sports
qui payent plus que d'autres mais
karathon je suis sûr et certain que pour
aller au tournoi il a déjà le premier
prix quoi au moins et après bah le reste
c'est benf quoi mais en fait ça se passe
bien en une semaine ils gagnent 120 000
quoi
après
bref après je sais pas top 10 oui ils
sont très à l'aise je pense que le top
30 mondial à 40 ça se passe quand même
pas mal mais après
après c'est plus dur quoi déjà il faut
enchaîner tendre derrière Quand tu es
dans le top 50 60 70 mondiale il faut
faire plein de tournois et tu fais
tourner en tournoi et en fait si jamais
chez toi tu vois c'est difficile parce
que les prix sont pas pareil quand tu
fais un open tu gagnes 3000 super c'est
bien mais il faut le gagner et après il
faut faire un autre etc quand tu fais un
tournoi comme ça tu gagnes même tu
arrives dernier tu gagnes déjà quoi tu
vois donc enfin tu as moins besoin de
jouer
que quand tu es moins fort et qu'ils ont
tous les tournois avec moins de prix
la question justement
ont pas mal d'avantages et les autres
rien ça dépend où tu te places même ce
qu'on disait les plus fort GM et en
vivre avoir vraiment des des grosses
sommes et pas de souci après dans ce qui
est tous les open
oui les titrés en général sont invités
les grands maîtres après plus facilement
mais les mettre aussi je pense qu'ils
ont
ils ont quasiment les mêmes avantages ou
du moins ils ont souvent des des sommes
données ou des hôtels payés des
conditions généralement quand tu fais un
tournoi tu peux avoir soit un petit
cachet
soit tu peux avoir
des aides voilà LED pour ton voyage pour
ton avion pour
avoir une chambre d'hôtel tu vas avoir
tu peux négocier pour avoir les repas
enfin tu peux toujours négocier après ça
prend que le tournoi mais bon plus tu es
fort peut-être en mission donc
mais généralement la base dans un vrai
tournoi un vrai tournoi
un open standard la basse c'est l'hôtel
déjà tu viens tu m'héberges et je joue
après plus d'effort comme
ils ont des conditions de malade et en
plus ils sont ils sont payés hyper bien
et en plus il y a beaucoup de prix ça
c'est encore différent quoi
ça dépend de ton niveau si moi je vais
tout si moi je faisais des toiles
toutes les semaines
je pense pas arriver à ce SMIC à la fin
de l'année je suis passé fort pour pour
faire un SMIC il faut gagner aller 1000
euros par mois en jouant aux échec mais
en fait je les ai jamais quoi déjà il y
a pas de toi tout le temps et quand il y
a un tournoi il faut toujours faire un
tri et quand tu fais un tournoi tu as
plein de grands mats qui viennent pour
avoir ces prix et en fait pour te dire
moi je pense que devenir
professionnel des échecs en tant que
joueur c'est minimum mais alors minimum
25 50
minimum
parce que tu as moins que ça tu galères
trop pour vivre ce qu'il va chaque fois
gagner des tournois pour pour manger
quoi simplement et en plus c'est
toujours tu es toujours en voyage tout
le temps tout le temps c'est en voyage
mais c'est dur de d'allier après ben
vite de famille ou quoi que ce soit tu
vois c'est compliqué quand tu es tout le
temps parti quoi donc c'est voilà après
il y a beaucoup de gens qui donnent des
cours comme le propose golden RAF mais
c'est pour ça que voilà mais
quelqu'un qui peut pas vivre juste de
ses gains de ces tournois bon on le voit
il y a énormément de joueurs d'échec qui
qui ont donné des cours ou diversifier
leurs activités d'une autre manière ou
sinon avoir un très bon niveau échecs
mais faire autre chose à côté et pas que
des échecs ça c'est plus compliqué parce
que ça veut dire que ton niveau d'échec
tu peux pas le
le maintenir ou l'améliorer facilement
si tu fais autre chose que des échecs
dans ce cas là
en tout cas c'est sûr que tu peux pas en
vivre
et après
il y a plein de grammates qui ne peuvent
pas être ça coûte enfin parce que c'est
trop dur enfin voilà quand 2600 et
l'autre tu commences à faire les
tournois et être invités avoir des
conditions un peu de partout et tu
commences vraiment quand tu fais un open
aller dans les favoris quoi mais il faut
savoir qu'après plus tu viens plus d'un
efface plus tu vieillis plus enfin moins
tes performant et plus c'est difficile
aussi de faire des prix en attendant
donc en fait tu choisis d'être pro et de
faire les tournois bien super mais dans
15 ans 20 ans est-ce que tu seras aussi
performant est-ce que tu vas continuer à
bien gagner ta vie enfin c'est un cas
assez difficile et c'est vrai que les
échecs c'est un monde c'est assez
difficile de pouvoir vivre en tant que
joueur si tu es vraiment pas dans le top
top
et c'est pour ça que la majorité des
gens même des grands maîtres donne des
cours fin du coaching fond autre chose à
côté parce que je sais que ça fait pas
assez bien malheureusement
Antoine disait 80 GM n'apporte pas grand
chose en réalité dans la compétition ce
sont à côté qui font vivre bah voilà
exactement
c'est un grand maître qui est très bon
il a 25 ans mais il a pas assez fort
pour pouvoir vivre des échecs ou alors
enfin c'est difficile on en a déjà parlé
mais c'est vrai que c'est
il est arrivé de partout il gagne bien
sa vie donc stressant
par mois bon c'est stressant mais
tu t'en sors quoi mais maintenant bon
quand tu es dans le top
comment personne
tu gagnes très bien ta vie donc bon ça
va quoi
il a pas de problème pour payer son
loyer quoi maintenant qu'il est streamer
donc c'est différent mais
tu vois ça veut dire mais c'est vrai que
pendant covid par exemple il y a plein
de points que tu organisé avec Carole
etc
et en fait il y a eu plein plein
d'argent qui a été qui était balancé
dans tout cet endroit là il distribuait
surtout au top niveau mais peu de
tournois organisé pour les grands
maîtres pro qui sont moins forts et
c'est vrai que au final un grand mec à
2005 s'il donne pas de cours c'est
compliqué quoi en fait tu fais quoi
donc bon c'est tout ça c'est c'est
de Magnus c'est pour ça qu'il faut
demander à Laurent mais je sais pas du
tout du montant j'en sais rien un golden
mais j'imagine que bon il paye la
qualité et puis
j'imagine que ça se passe bien en tout
cas mais après encore une fois ça faudra
voir avec Laurent et Laurent il est en
train de jouer en ce moment le Top 12
alors Fatou on n'a pas encore fait un
tour entier
est-ce que on peut rester 30 secondes
sur cette partie on a vu que
on a parlé du cavalier A3 de Ali resa
qui qui semblait être bien préparé et
finalement il a mis en minutes
un peu spécial alors que les Noirs comme
tu tu l'avais annoncé suivre juste leur
plan de base donc le rock F6 avec l'idée
de cavalier F7 et on va y aller
tranquillement
donc les blancs cramé du temps je sais
pas trop pourquoi du coup
il se pose plein de questions alors
peut-être que c'est deux aussi c'est une
idée sur le long terme c'est possible
par rapport au pire doublé c'est 5 et 6
si je ne m'abuse question de savoir si
[Musique]
c'était pas problématique et alors oui
et non et dans ce cas là non après ça
dépend des positions ça dépend aussi
s'ils sont isolés donc s'il y a pas
d'autres pions pour les accompagner là
on voit qu'ils sont vers le centre qui
prennent des qui contrôle des cases et
on va pouvoir en échanger un des deux à
tout moment dès que les blancs vont
vouloir avancer parce qu'il contrôle
bien le centre et les blancs vont
vouloir eux reprendre le centre et dans
ce cas là il y aura plus ces deux pions
doublés puisque l'un des deux va être
échangé
ouais et d'ailleurs je dirais même plus
en fait
les blancs ils font pas de Paris si tu
veux en jouant la ressort Immo les
blancs font peu le pari d'échanger leur
avantage de paire de fou pour casser la
structure de noir tu vois et donc ça
fait exprès les vents les blancs veulent
jouer contre leur structure qui est pas
terrible mais pour ça je donne un fou
donc il y a un petit problème qui me
structure c'est vrai
et même si un jour comme tu l'as dit
Fatou j'arrive à jouer des 4 et ben
j'aurais toujours un petit problème sur
la structure dans le sens où si je parle
des Cinq puis on sera un petit peu
arriéré tout le temps si je fais des six
qui apprennent normal standard dans ce
dans ces positions le pion c'est
toujours un petit peu en arrière tu vois
on sent qu'il y a mon espace chez les
noirs
de fou c'est le prix à payer en fait tu
vois je peux pas tout avoir mais là les
Blancs ont sacrifié entre guillemets la
paire de fou alors le sacrifié parce que
la part de fou c'est c'est très
important surtout à ce niveau là et mais
en contrepartie il y a un problème un
peu sur la structure voilà donc c'est un
pari sur le long terme les deux quand
joue sur leur avantage mutuellement
donc oui il y a un problème mais c'est
pas si grave sera compensé par la
compensé par les fous voilà
donc ouais 600 on va jouer
4 c'est des
et après le cavalier on sait pas encore
il va aller ça on va voir un peu ce que
nous prépare ici il y a
on va tourner un petit peu est-ce qu'on
peut aller voir peut-être Google
à tous ceux qui arrivent bien sûr
n'hésitez pas à envoyer des messages
même si on lit pas tout
on vous regarde même si on lit pas au
doigts
est-ce que dans une prédiction on peut
aussi mettre la nul ou est-ce que c'est
pas possible parce qu'en fait ce que
l'argent ce qu'on a fait c'est que la
prédiction tu paries Hikaru ou à lireza
mais s'il y a match nul et ben en fait
la prédiction elle reste pour les
emmagas en fait
tu peux faire plusieurs tu peux faire
cinq choix mais si tu fais une
prédiction tu dois pouvoir en faire que
de
tout le monde qui qui sacrifie tout son
argent
on devrait mettre des notes en jeu
000 noces pardon
qui est Fatou ben incroyable Maxime il
connaît pas Fatou
Maximus qui ne connaît pas Fatou je
qu'est-ce qu'on lui fait à Maximus Fatou
enchanté bonjour Maximus
malheureusement je l'ai en stream pas on
est
le
norbet de chasse mais bien sûr je
je suis je regarde
je suis partiellement on essaie de
suivre entre deux trucs on va dire
[Musique]
on a aussi Mazet qui joue mvl Bacro en
fait toute chose
et l'année prochaine en plus il reste
les prochains l'année prochaine
l'année prochaine
voilà l'année prochaine il y a d'abord
Samir Robin avec Nathan les deux sont
dans le même club et leur club est monté
pour jouer en Top 16 l'année prochaine
et mon club aussi kanechec c'est aussi
qualifié pour jouer de l'année prochaine
en Top 16 donc en fait l'année prochaine
il y aura vraiment tout le monde sauf
Fatou voilà Fatou qui fera les
commentaires tout seul
[Rires]
pauvre de moi voilà très bien
après tu es pas obligé de dire tout ça
tu peux tu peux dire la vérité
carabistouille là on a compris que tu
essayes de
enjoliver un peu les choses mais
on va faire la partie
alors je mets le truc de custom
donc
hop trois
petits tours
OK
on dirait qu'il joue tout un peu envoyer
le temps qu'il a guéri la pendule
et donc c'est vraiment son point fort
donc là on voit 1h50 bon je me fais un
peu
cavalue 5 d'accord ici on a vu le coût
F4 qui a un coût assez bizarre de la
part de de bocage alors pourquoi bizarre
parce qu'on met des pions en fait sur la
couleur d'un trou
et d'ailleurs ce foulard qui peut pas
encore bouger donc j'imagine que plus
tard une idée de Google ça va être de
jouer peut-être j'ai trois ou G4 pour
mettre le fond en G2 peut-être
il a commencé par ouvrir un petit peu la
position sa KF4 ça pose des problèmes
sur la structure généralement je sais
pas
c'est un coup qui me que j'aime pas trop
un coup comme 4 paraissait plus normal
dans la position
4 et 3
ça paraissait plus normal mais après je
suis pas un expert du tout de la
pollution
quand même là je peux pas aller ici
parce qu'il va manger
donc je serai peut-être aller en E1
quand même pour venir en F2 ou en G3
d'ailleurs aussi
et après j'aurais bougé madame pour
essayer d'aller manger là peut-être
mais une potion qui est très théorique
apparemment quand tu vois le temps de
d'anus
dans l'impression que bon c'est ce qui
fait quoi donc
j'ai l'impression qu'ici à Nice a pas de
problème
il va OK et la position elle est alors
B3 Titi j'aime pas du tout
aïe aïe aïe j'aime pas non désolé
pourquoi j'aime pas tu as déjà tu as
deux pions seulement pour défendre ton
droit
si tu bouges un attention à tous les
trous que tu peux faire là ta structure
elle est importante il faut garder des
cases un maximum il faut pas se laisser
envahir et B3 regarde quelle casse tu
vas laisser
je te laisse regarder
B3 il y a tout qui
devient noir
et de manière générale en plus c'est pas
un bon réflexe de de bouger les pions là
où tu es faible ton why est faible
droite tout seul ici bouge pas les
tenues voilà
donc là le cavalier il est là
généralement tu vas manger comme ça
en tout cas ce qu'on veut faire
et donc c'est pas mal à la tour et de
libérer le fou c'est mieux mais B3
évitent évite évite ce genre de cours
cave à les prendre
excuse-moi j'ai eu peur
j'ai fait un clic droit ici
je suis un clic droit et un clic droit
comment j'ai fait
je sais pas ce que j'ai fait mais j'ai
pas fait exprès mais j'ai joué tout seul
pardon
désolé là je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé qui a écrit
je comprenais pas ok
mais non non mais B3 tu laisses cavaler
à trois échecs tu laisses plein de
choses et ton roi il devient vraiment
trop ouvert quoi donc éviter de bouger
les plantes du roi sans raison
donc la F3 est-ce que je peux roquer ou
te torser 8 un des deux même tomber vite
aussi il y a un vis-à-vis qui peut être
intéressant un jour
peut-être qu'avec un tueur à emprise et
ben je vais la mettre ici pour anticiper
le placement de la tour sur le roi c'est
marrant
ça ça et ça commence à chauffer un peu
pour pour les blancs mais bon
la position elle reste très vite
tu peux jouer au centre
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que même sur un comme on
peut dire c'était pas si je peux avoir
du jeu est-ce que tu penses que je peux
avoir du jeu sur la colonne h
ou est-ce que c'est trop trop
longtemps en fait ça paraît lointain et
oser ouais alors que les recomposés on
sait qu'on a envie de de balancer d'y
aller on attaque
et là les Noirs paraissent plus
dangereux que les blancs
mais quand je serai à 5 il faudra
sacrifier la qualité ou alors faire
d'abord ça ça mais si je fais G4 j'ai 5
il fait cavalier H5 qui m'a bloqué
peut-être j'ai quatre H5 mais bon c'est
un peu long et
donc avoir
mais bon c'est une idée qui peut arriver
en tout cas sur un malentendu
attaquer les pièces noires vont tout
aller du côté droit blanc et oui ça les
deux tours ici et peut-être le cavalier
un jour enlever le devant du roi bref
c'est pas c'est pas simple ok est-ce
qu'on a une autre partie rock a été joué
on a une autre partie à avoir on n'a pas
vu ma médium
[Musique]
que Carlson un jeu contre saw on va voir
après
ma mère
[Musique]
saut ici alors l'ouverture
c'est quoi cette ouverture
comme ça tu me demandes
[Musique]
allez je vais dire non mais ça peut être
ça
en plus je te promets
en ce moment donc j'ai failli
en plus il y a eu la même partie plein
de fois
je suis vraiment
je suis pas bon
OK
donc là il y a clairement le combat pour
la case des 5
forte du centre de l'échelier et les
blancs peuvent y aller donc les Noirs
ils vont essayer de te le défendre donc
on peut voir un coup comme vous aussi je
pense arriver pour essayer de manger des
cinq dès que le cavalier a franchi la
casse quoi
donc faut aussi ce m'a l'air très
correct
ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu penses là tu
es d'accord
en fait
je vois F4 je me dis que le cavalier a
pas de case ici
j'ai pu reculer si je vais là j'ai pas
la case C3 malheureusement pour le
cavalier mais quand je bouge mon
cavalier là il y a une fourchette déjà
la rentrée
des pions alors je sais pas dans quel
sens je sais pas si c'est bien ou pas
mais je me dis que ça peut
F5 que j'aime pas trop parce qu'après le
fou va partir et je peux plus tard sur
le long terme je ne casse pour le
cavalier en E5 qui peut revenir être pas
mal mettez de l'autre côté le fou joue
plus quoi
mais si je joue F5 je sais pas où tu vas
parce que j'étais du F5 derrière ça
tu vois là
et en fait je me dis que fou aussi
peut-être ça va accélérer l'attaque
et d'ailleurs il est à jour car il est 3
je l'avais même pas vu mais c'est
clairement le bon coup en fait la vallée
3 c'est très bien joué ça part
qu'elle est bien placé ici et tu as pas
trop envie de te mettre en
vis-à-vis de la tour donc tu vas
probablement manger et quand tu manges
là la tour qui mange tu pourras plus
tard faire faux aussi et en fait les
Noirs ici c'est un problème parce qu'ils
avaient pas de casse pour se cavalier
et pour amuser enfin pour anticiper la
poussée centrale aussi des pions on
n'avait pas trop de cases moi tout
cavaliers
pour te dire
au final je vais manquer de cases en
fait tu te rendes compte que le cavalier
le 5 c'est un problème ça qui est
important de se rendre compte c'est un
problème que sur F4 et ben je manque de
casse comme tu l'as dit
et là qui avait les trois c'est parfait
en fait là il va y avoir
c'est mais attention Cadillac
parce que la tour elle peut plus trop
trop rentrer en arrière c'est ça en
l'air je la bouge je ne sais pas où
je sais pas je vais danser
la carte des deux peut-être un jour pour
une pièce
alors A6 non un Maximus il y avait qui
cette fourchette
mais peut-être dame j'ai 5 mais j'ai
encore F4 qui faut regarder écoute
j'aime beaucoup les blancs ici
mais
il veut faire fou aussi c'est s'en
débarrasser mais il faut aussi sortir
des cas je C4 et quand tu manges en
dessin que je mange d'un pion plutôt du
Pione je pense
et ou même pu penser les deux coups sont
intéressants mais la tour elle est un
petit peu enfermée j'ai peur de la tour
j'ai peur de la perdre tu sais quoi ça
est-ce que tu as le choix oui
mais bon ça c'est une grande décision
oui bah oui mais je suis pas sûr que tu
as assez de jeu quand même
du couloir ça marche moi
écoute j'aime beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
les blancs ici
il y a un vis-à-vis un cavalier
monstruant de 5 en pratique c'est un
cauchemar
pour les noirs
je trouve que ça
d'avoir les blancs et je pense qu'en
plus c'est une position qui
qui va bien à ma manière c'est une
position active c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'il veut quoi
pousser un avantage
et je verrai bien un petit point de ma
meilleure avant cette partie
hier Fabi avec les noirs qui avait une
grosse partie d'ailleurs
contre un carburant qui était hyper en
forme dans ce tournoi
donc je verrais bien ma médiérophe
marqué d'être un deuxième point
d'affilée
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup la position
des blancs parce que tu vois dans tous
les cas même si jamais tu arrives à
faire ça et manger j'aurais un pion
passé quoi
je sais pas comment tu fais mais
[Musique]
je parle même ça
même juste
ça je sais pas même manger même faire ça
en fait cette position si tu veux elle
m'a l'air tellement bien pour les blancs
je sais pas de quoi je mange
je te reprends c'est très bien j'ai
quand même ma colonne et je peux doubler
sur la colonne est rentré en 7e
je peux aussi avoir pu passer juste
protéger c'est fort
je pense quand même si on prend alarme
ok écoute j'aime beaucoup la pause de ma
mère
et la dernière partie qu'on a pas eu
c'est la position
beaucoup à la partie de Carl Seine avec
les Blancs contre sceau qu'on a eu à la
ronde 2 ou 3 je ne sais plus à quel
endroit on a eu cette partie
et en fait c'est la fameuse espagnole
bizarre d'échange que
D3 on retarde un petit peu la prise en 6
voilà
et on joue petit rock et ensuite
c'est un peu la même chose je trouve que
c'est différent en fait dans la partie
de saut je crois qu'il avait déjà avec
kevalier c'est trois il me semble
comment
mais noir avait le cavalier 7 F6 rock
une cabellion F8 etc c'est après
standard et apparemment les Blancs
avaient joué
avec B3 et comment il avait déjà
il a fait des manœuvres avec un cavalier
en D2 C4 et très souvent dans ces
positions avec les Blancs tu joues un
truc comme ça et puis surtout je
pourrais F4 pour ouvrir la position
souvent qui se jouent comme ça genre 6
cavalent
cavaler 6 suivi de F4 ça c'est les
prisons qui sont assez thématiques mais
ici
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
avait joué avec F3
et plus tard j'ai quatre H4 ça c'est
marrant et là on voit que Abdou a joué
aussi avec F3
alors il a joué
mal placé ici
quel est le 5 cavaliers je crois
ok alors on va expliquer
Robin side alors oui on va essayer
d'expliquer le cavalier G5 cavalier
alors en fait
position
parce que le fou 6 bon on veut le
chasser de sa belle case dans le cyder
souvent avant de mettre un four en 6
très souvent on aime bien faire H6
d'abord
puis ça ça etc pour empêcher le canal G5
maintenant dans la position ce qui se
passe après faut aussi cavaler B3 B6 car
il y a 5 mais non pas fait H6 donc on
peut jeter 5 pour aller essayer de
embêter ce fou maintenant on joue fou G4
et on fait F3 donc dans cette position
qui sont encore lentes et fermées il y a
pas vraiment de de tension au centre
donc la production est fermée donc je
peux me permettre
après F3 fois H5 le Fou est un peu
hors-jeu le foot est bien placé sur une
belle diagonale là et en venant ici et
ben écoute maintenant le fou va être mal
placé donc cavalier G5 plus tard les
Noirs vont jouer avec
moi j'aurais fait son prochain coup tu
vois donc c'est pareil mais
c'est un peu le prix à payer en tout cas
il y a ici pour avoir le fou sur une
mauvaise diagonale ensuite ce qui a se
passer c'est que noir peut aussi jouer
F7
plus tard replacer de fou sur une bonne
diagonale
mais moi mon cavalier il était là je
vais bouger mais peut-être que de toute
façon j'ai aussi besoin de bouger le
cavalier pour jouer F4 sur le long terme
donc dans les deux cas j'ai l'impression
que ça ça
les Blancs ont besoin en fait c'est
marrant mais les Blancs ont besoin de
jouer à un moment donné leur cavalier
pour GF4
et en Jank avec G5 je gagne un pseudo
temps pour jouer qu'à aller à 5 et F4
mais ici les blancs font fougères donc
le four est mal placé mais pour après le
replay sur une bonne case je bouge le
cavalier et F6 en fait je perds
pour passer le fou sur une bonne case tu
vois c'est vraiment une sorte de temps
parce que moi aussi je parle du temps
donc là plus tard le fou il va revenir
en E6 c'est une évidence
cavalue aussi pour venir en décape ou F4
c'est peut-être aussi un une bonne idée
souvent on joue cavalier aussi c'est 5 à
et D4
et le cavalier en H3 il est mal placé
certes mais je peux m'en placer et donc
plusieurs idées soi-dames pour m'enlever
d'ici et F4 je reste dans
G5 H3 pour au final jouer F4
soit peut-être plus positionnel je
cavalier F2 et c'est tricoté au centre
ça on va voir un peu ce qu'il va nous
faire mais F4 ça reste quand même une
idée
assez standard donc c'est position
cette structure quoi
donc non c'est intéressant cavalier 5
tu es dans un club qu'elle ne serait pas
salut Alicia
on va voir car ça ne tarif on a fait un
petit tour mais ça c'est comme des
positions Abdou Garau qui sont
assez égales généralement quoi où il se
passe
généralement pas grand chose
je joue pour le club de canechec je sais
pas si c'était la question par rapport à
mon club et je suis coach aussi je donne
des cours effectivement là maintenant il
y a pas la commande cours que que
m'avait préparé mon petit Yuma mais si
vous voulez me contacter peut-être que
Yumi dans le chat si jamais dans le chat
peut-être qui peut nous
transférer copier coller
peut-être le lien du site ou un truc
comme ça j'ai un site internet donne des
cours depuis de nombreuses années donc
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à me contacter
si vous avez besoin si vous voulez
progresser aux échecs
donc voilà l'idée c'est de manger ici
de récupérer la paire de fou et
peut-être plus tard je déteste
par exemple sur quoi qui Roque
est une option claire un truc comme ça
et jouer champion de 6 c'est une option
clairement et maintenant on va taper sur
les cases noires ça paraît logique tout
ça
donc voilà merci beaucoup pour ton
pour ton petit lien donc pour me
contacter c'est facile je stream
quasiment tous les jours sauf le
week-end et sauf pendant les événements
de chaisescom qui prennent beaucoup de
temps donc là je suis pas en string
depuis plusieurs jours à cause de ça
mais pour me contacter sur discord sur
sur
twitch sur Just com
donc c'est tout enfin envoyer un stuff
sous mon nom et prénom vous me trouvez
de partout vous avez mes coordonnées de
partout
et Fatou aussi il me semble Fatou
oh donc oui mais tu es un des cours
voilà ça m'arrive voilà donc si vous
voulez progresser avec avec Fatou aussi
n'hésitez pas à la contacter elle donne
des cours en allemand aussi pour
en allemand des cours d'allemand en
échec si vous voulez
si vous voulez allier
finalement
F4 était une idée mais en fait non il va
tourner alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il joue
cavaler j'ai il veut se recycler
peut-être alors j'ai trois option
des 4 et qu'elle va les prendre les
quatre
et en fait il y a plein d'options il y a
deux ruptures il y a F4 D4 comme rupture
centrale donc il se les garde en tout
cas je garde les options différentes et
Karlsen a une potion un petit peu de ce
même style en tout cas dans la même
structure
G4 H4 car c'est pas du tout la même
position donc mais c'est la même
structure que je contrôle sa
est-ce qu'on va voir un petit peu dans
un mix Carlson contre contre Paris
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
allons voir 45 qui a joué qui enjeu H5
H5 c'est un con intéressant on va
expliquer pourquoi ce qu'on joue à
disposition je reviens un petit peu au
début on s'est arrêté
il faut
et c'est 4 ok
on remplace le fou pour jouer un marozzi
et en fait avec toute cette idée de
faire fouter tout ça et bien il a placé
le cavalier en D7 qui n'est pas
forcément la meilleure cache du cavalier
dans la Normandie
4 B6
et Magnus qui joue une position de type
hérisson
c'est pas le hérisson ça pique
c'est pas une blague
ah c'est vrai en plus c'est vraiment le
hérisson
et donc à 6 x 3 tours c'est un tour
évidemment des deux H5 donc il y a plein
donc souvent le hérisson il y a aussi il
y a quand même le fou en E7
c'est dans le vrai hérisson le Fou est
un recettes il y a des plans très
marrants à base de dames C7 dame B8
et le fou qui vient en D8 et en C7
pour taper sur le roi avec la perte de
poids
c'est la position typique du hérisson
mais là je pense pas qu'il va faire
aussi c'est qu'il va être s'en fout je
pense pas qu'il va faire ça s'en
déjà bien en G7
typique et qui voulait
une chanson
pas la chanson
la chanson de ciel bleu
ça me dit rien non plus
donc voilà bon H5 pourquoi H5
[Musique]
pour éviter G4
[Rires]
non parce que j'ai 4 c'est pas mon en
fait les blancs prennent le centre
généralement le blanc vont jouer de ce
côté-là
par exemple
BK qui avait les B3 et A4 à 5 c'est
implant thématique dans sa position
je pense sur case noir
[Musique]
on a peur que toi-même tu passes H4
maintenant H5 dans le hérisson
c'est pour ancrer le cavalier G4 si
Blanc joue F4 très bien voilà alors ça
c'est une des idées ciel bleu c'est très
bien en fait l'idée bien sûr c'est que
souvent un des plans des blancs de jouer
au centre mais par contre vu que les
Noirs jouent avec comme ça et mettre le
fou ici
[Musique]
F4 c'est un coup qui est difficile à
faire tout le temps à cause du pion en 4
qui est souvent pression donc F4 c'est
pas quand même enfin c'est pas trop trop
l'idée dans la production des blancs
parce que à cause de ce pion mais c'est
vrai qu'avec H5 déjà je sais que si un
jour il défend pion suffisamment et qui
joue F4 je pourrais aller en G4 mais
c'est pas tout
l'idée d'âge 5 parce que vu que là les
blancs font pas F4 quand même
donc je bouge un pion du roi donc
attention de chez vous ne faites pas 5
tout le temps c'est pas forcément bien
mais ici
ce qui se passe c'est qu'après après
après H5 déjà ça
je peux me permettre de jouer sur deux
coups
[Musique]
je veux faire en fait H4
et faire éventuellement un coup comme H3
plus tard pour provoquer un
investissement chez les Blancs de G3 qui
ouvrirait cette belle diagonale ça c'est
une idée autre idée souvent c'est le
surcas noir donc comme je fais avec bon
c'est celle d'un B8 c'est le fou qui
vient en C7 souvent quand je fais H4 on
voit ce plan très souvent dans même des
positions des stendiennes ou en fait
imaginons un truc comme ça bateau et ben
souvent le fait de jouer H4 ça me laisse
la classe pour cavalier en H5 et plus
tard peut-être même que je pourrais
attaquer sur case noire par exemple je
découvre en bateau
avec du Fou au sein qui peut arriver qui
peut attaquer ici une dame noire qui
peut arriver aussi facilement peut-être
des fois sur case noir donc là il y a un
fou mais peut venir en F6 quoi et en
fait je peux souvent attaquer commencer
l'attaque là-bas et c'est assez
difficile pour les blancs
et plus tard j'ai quand même des idées
sur case Nord et c'est intéressant et je
le garde toujours le cash 3 un jour si
la pollution
s'ouvre et donc sur le hérisson de
manière générale et ben les Noirs
commencent on va dire avec très peu
d'espace
mais plus tard une fois qu'ils sont
prêts les Noirs vont essayer tout ouvrir
avec des cinq on va essayer de tout
casser
le centre une fois que je serai prêt et
c'est pour ça que avoir le pion qui
menace de t'arriver en H3 quand la
position elle s'ouvre ça peut être pas
mal aussi donc H5 c'est un coup
intéressant qui prépare un peu tout ça
bien sûr le prochain car ça ne sera pas
H4 parce que H4 le pion est peut-être en
danger directement
mais c'est vrai que je prépare je
prépare c'est un coup de profil optique
par rapport à G4 c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment vraiment
un coup aussi profil actifs
tous les plans pourraient faire
que pourraient faire les blancs et bien
sûr si elle bleu qui rapporte encore de
cavaluation bien sûr
a suscité beaucoup de
[Musique]
on a commencé à l'heure
ça commence à 17h comme d'hab
c'est quoi la meilleure façon
d'apprendre à connaître les formes de
défense
et d'attaque
les structures qu'il faut comprendre
plutôt que
apprendre à connaître en fait c'est
comprendre quelle structure engendre
quoi
donc
par rapport aux structures de ça
forme de défense et d'attaque
j'aurais du mal à dire autre chose
en fait il y a plein de stratégies
Alicia peut-être que tu pars de
stratégie en fait de manière générale la
stratégie c'est une des c'est vraiment
une des phases du jeu qui sont les plus
difficiles à travailler tout seul parce
qu'on parle vraiment de compréhension de
le jeu et souvent tu as besoin de
quelqu'un qui t'explique les choses donc
il y a plein de bouquins qui sont très
très bien sur leur stratégie
des bouquins qui sont même en français
je pourrais te donner des titres mais
c'est un peu la stratégie qu'il te faut
je pense
donc comment placer les pièces comment
placer les pièces pour avoir de
l'attaque je vous rappelle que pour
avoir de la tactique que tout le monde
vous dit que c'est important de pouvoir
faire de la tactique aux échec calculer
etc c'est bien beau mais si vous avez
pas de base placez bien vos pièces dans
les parties et là c'est difficile parce
que si les pièces sont pas bien placées
genre pas de tactique en fait les deux
vont ensemble il y a vraiment un lien
entre la stratégie et la tactique ça
c'est clair si tu as la pièce bien
placée et ben tu vas être récompenser
par une tactique si tes pièces sont mal
placées tu mérites pas une tactique bon
des fois tu en as mais généralement non
voilà
alors que justement la stratégie tu sais
est-ce que la l'ouverture tu mets
en quand tu passes tes pièces les
premières choses que tu apprends c'est à
placer des pièces dans l'ouverture
et après la tactique est découle de ça
mais il est vraiment tactique
enfin
pour moi
alors oui alors je vais Andreas qui
avait demandé au début il faut acheter
ça alors déjà faut acheter c'est pas
forcément le bon coup en fait faut h6 il
y a beaucoup de position où on aime bien
changer les fous de son gâteau des noirs
mais souvent souvent avec le l'objectif
d'attaquer le Renoir ici les blancs avec
ces quatre qui sont pas dans l'optique
de ramener l'attaque de maths sont plus
dans l'optique de prendre de l'espace et
de de cette poussée au fur et à mesure
les positions avec grand rock par
exemple la Sicilienne
étant H1
là je pourrais essayer de faire H4 H5
vous savez mettre un four en H6 changer
les fous ouvrir la colonne h vous voyez
si jamais vous voyez que vous avez une
grosse attaque sur le roi noir vous
pouvez parfois H6 pour essayer
d'attaquer et d'échanger et passer
maintenant dans la position je vois pas
comment on peut attaquer quoi là on a
une position très solide on a l'avantage
d'espace avec les Blancs on a une belle
structure des belles cases tout ça
jouer fois H6 je pense que il va te
manquer plus tard dans ta position
le fout de case noire qui fait quand
même un bon rôle pour l'instant il est
très bien ici le fou ici est très bien
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas c'est pas
la priorité d'aller manger des fois je
sais quoi
en plus il y aura peut-être même fois je
suis très possible je suis pas sûr que
faut juste un bon coup non plus mais
juste pour vous dire que je l'ai rien
forcé et t'en fous il fait quoi
maintenant il fait rien
donc ça souvent tu m'as pratiquement si
on pousse les pions sur le roi et les
pièces oui je suis d'accord Andreas mais
si mon roi est ici recopposé s'appelle
grand rock contre BOTY rock on met des
foules à eau on échange des fous on
pousse les pions on ouvre les colonnes
là on est rock en face
j'ai des pions du roi ben ouais
j'attaque mais mon rail à poil enfin
c'est pas comme ça qu'on attaque des
fois il y a des on a vu car c'est une
grosse saut entre on en a parlé ou
cartoon il a fait j'ai quatre H4 c'est
très très polissons qui sont très c'est
exceptions quoi mais de manière générale
tu balances pas G4 comme ça de manière
générale c'est
avec ton roi derrière non donc c'est
pour ça que la fois H6 j'aime pas parce
que tu n'as pas la taxe derrière en fait
qu'il te faudrait et une fois que tu
changes les fous
ben tu sens qu'il te manque des pièces
au centre dites-moi qu'un foulard quoi
pour consolider le centre total
l'avantage au centre donc garde tes
pièces au centre pour l'instant c'est
mon conseil la meuf de a été joué
regarde malin hop il se place là
peut-être qu'il pourra passer par là-bas
on se place donc
voilà quoi je pense qu'il va y avoir
plus tard un cavalier B3 alors souvent
soit on joue avec B4 plus cavaler B3
puis on pousse le pion en 4 à 5 c'est un
plan très connu dans dans la marozzi
mais on peut aussi jouer directement
cavalier B3
avec du A4 à 5 sachant que sur cavalier
B3 est A4 si les Noirs jouent à 5 pour
empêcher et ben ils font cadeau la belle
case en dessin qui pour le cavalier donc
voilà le 6 standard en contre la case
des 5
et puis on prépare je pense qu'elle va
aller le 5 qui va arriver un jour
bientôt parce que les Noirs aussi vont
taper sur le conserve
donc pour l'instant c'est une position
qui est j'ai envie de dire à cette
tranquille c'est normal voilà donc
Tanguy oui je donne des cours d'échec
tout à l'heure on en a parlé alors il
avait mis mon l'adresse de mon site
internet sur le chat je sais pas si il
met encore là fallait épingler
on va pas l'épingler mais si tu as
besoin en tout cas tant de Guy tu me
contactes tu connais mon pseudo c'est
stouf m'écrire sur tous les réseaux
sociaux je suis sur sur
cheesecom déjà sur twitch sur
discord suite partout tu peux m'écrire
en termes mail tu as toutes les infos de
partout sur internet
et salut
il empêche H4
qui empêche 4
je parlais de quoi avant déjà
H4 j'apporte pourquoi je peux pas H4
sur le long terme oui oui bon mais pour
l'instant c'est pour l'instant H4
c'était un coup qui est affaiblissant
mais sur le long terme ça peut être un
bon goût c'est une idée qu'on peut avoir
plus tard quand on arrive à essayer
d'ouvrir la position avec le noir et
pour l'instant effectivement d'un point
H4 ça va pas du tout on est bien
d'accord
mais simple mais même dommage 4 fougères
5 ça peut être une idée
blanc est quand même plus à l'ail dame
on est plus par là-bas quoi donc B4 à 4
à 5 ou cavalier B3 à 4 c'est plus par
là-bas qu'on va qu'on va faire le jeu
donc en tout cas c'est une potion
intéressante ou les Blancs ont toujours
un petit avantage quand même dans ces
positions de maroczi donc c'est très
solide tu as un gros centre il y a plein
de possibilités
il a 200 points de plus c'est l'eau
quand même il y a pas gagné une seule
partie il joue beaucoup de gens qui est
le dernier
il va vouloir gagner la partie
mais
pas voir
avoir
on n'a pas fait de pronos enfin tout ce
que tu veux en faire
entre nous
alors cette partie cartonne qu'est-ce
que tu qu'est-ce que tu paries toi
moi je vais parler
qu'est-ce que tu dis
[Musique]
je réfléchis
rapide favoriser quand même vachement
maintenant
les vacances arrivent la France d'été
2 mois avoir 3 mois quasiment deux
vacances pour pouvoir bien travailler
les échecs
en Paris je suis nul de chez nul mais
alors tu faisais quoi là
[Musique]
c'est un joueur que j'aime énormément
qui m'a fait perdre plein de Paris
je parie en fait mais bon pas toujours
mais des fois
ça m'a fait nul contre qui je le gardien
mettre des
résultats Mamet
pas je vais pas changer
en tout cas
[Musique]
alors je te rappelle qu'ils sont joués
dans
avec Laurent
et il y a eu deux matchs entre les deux
joueurs et vraiment à gagner les deux
matchs
contre carbone c'était 2,5
et c'est pour cette raison que je vais
dire nul
est-ce que je peux parler comme toi ou
pas
je t'autorise
j'ai tendance à dire le résultat inverse
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
a perdu hier il pète tranquille les deux
joueurs vont jouer pour gagner tous les
deux là j'ai mis 5 rivales décisifs j'ai
pas mis une seule nul je crois que je
suis fou
je suis un peu déçu parce que
le garage n'a pas répondu quoi
alors
le soleil se couche le grand pas
alors donc alors
sur quelle partie tu veux aller Fatou
est-ce qu'il y a des parties
intéressantes parce que là on a juste
nos Paris
par exemple firounaka c'est un peu ce
qu'on avait dit
évidemment on est très très fort le
fondateur tu le sais
[Musique]
C3 petit rock 6 comme on l'avait prédit
des quatre prises T5 comme on l'avait
prédit on avait dit que le pion allait
bouger et qu'au final et puis on sait si
sa lettre à l'arrière donc là on peut
imaginer d'être un B3
celui de tours alors l'idée n'a qu'à
peut-être peut-être
si je suis malin comme lui
regarde
vis-à-vis là
est-ce que c'est pas de faire ça
pour faire ça
et faire ça
parce que par hasard
en fait c'est des Noirs arrivent à
échanger des pions surtout ce pion CC ce
qui me faiblesse les noirs peuvent avoir
un avantage parce que le problème de la
position des blancs
c'est qu'ils ont pas la paire de fou et
que les Noirs la possède et que les
caches blanches peuvent être faible il y
a que si la position s'ouvre vraiment
comme ça que tous les points ça change
au milieu les vivre
avantage noir grâce à la barre de fou
voilà donc
j'ai peur de ça et surtout prends il
faut F5
bon j'ai encore
qui bouge et que je bouge ma tour je
pars encore là
c'est pas simple cette pause
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici
je peux juste donner le pion
quand même mais en fait je peux donner
s'il y a un truc concret mais quand je
dis Barbade
donc
si je fais ça par exemple et que tu
prends et maintenant tu fais ces 5
maintenant parce que j'ai envie de fou
et du coup je contrôle des cinq mais
même problème qu'avant j'ai encore fait
F5 oups
et la position s'ouvre sur case blanche
et ça c'est pas forcément bon signe pour
les blancs
pas sûr que les blancs soient bien
s'éclate
pas si simple encore mais c'est vrai que
c'est la position elle s'ouvre les Noirs
auront l'avantage des fous donc là je
pense qu'il faut être très concret avec
les Blancs
eux prend des 4
c'est prendre des 5 dans le B3
j'imagine que tu parles de
tu parles de ça j'imagine
Goldor mesdames
à l'avantage
et la part de fou chez
[Musique]
les noirs
la position elle est standards
7 pour défendre lui après plus tard
avoir si je fais le 5 ou pas mais il y a
la barre de fou depuis on voulait là je
vois pas en quoi les Blancs ont un
avantage
je pense également
au mieux c'est
là en tout cas 40 minutes de retard ah
oui mais c'est vrai que là il est lent à
livraison et contre Naka à faire
attention ce qu'on a qu'à c'est un petit
filou
on pensait que c'était bien préparé et
finalement tu viens plus de 20 minutes à
jouer le coup suivant dans l'ouverture
perdre autant de temps c'est sévère
donc il va peut-être payer je t'avoue
que c'est un petit peu pour ça que j'ai
misé sur ma carte
alors pourquoi la chose
pas comprendre exactement ce que le
blanc peut faire ici
si vraiment il y a un truc là pour les
blancs
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment un truc où
est-ce que on considère juste que
qu'ils ont un petit avantage et qui vont
le garder
je pensais à ça
j'ai tellement pas envie de le donner
je suis content de donner quand même
[Musique]
que tout à l'heure c'était toujours les
fous qui vont s'ouvrir sur carte blanche
et on garde ce pion faible mettez notre
côté si un jour je mets le four en
dessin que mon fou il est fort et je
défends je défends j'attaque je suis
actif et
il y a un problème réel
c'est pas du tout dans l'esprit ton roi
il est ouvert je mangeais j'aurais
vraiment fou non non
tout ce qui tu as fait là tout ce qu'il
faut pas faire ça
c'est pas bon
salut
tous les joueurs qui sont là Alicia tous
les joueurs qui sont là c'est les
meilleurs du monde il a joué 5 quoi je
regardais ça mais bon j'étais pas sûr
que ça j'ai regardé et je me suis dit
non
souvent la réaction sort de 5 c'est le 5
dans cette structure mais là il y avait
un problème
depuis embête de pardon et c'est ça que
en plus quand tu prends mes deux tu
attaques
mais bon je rentre à la maison et tu as
réussi quoi en fait
peut-être juste ça
dans quel sens je pense que je vais
faire ça
je suis un petit malin je suis des
menaces doubles
et puis quand tu prends là je prends du
cavale je pense
tu prends du Fou bah merci pour les
cases noires moi je serais mon casque
noir qui pourra t'attaquer tes tiennes
non je pensais pas mal
en fait si vraiment ce pion il est pas
prenable en tout cas s'il y a du jeu
comme ça c'est intéressant mais c'est
que 5 c'est le plan un peu standard dans
ces positions
dans ces positions
oui mais en fait non
enfin ça va
je pense à même puis on prend un
possible d'ailleurs
parce que je pense que tu as pas envie
d'échanger ton fou contre le cavalier
donc plus fort ici
toi tu prends le corps à tout point du
vent du cavalier
[Musique]
je préfère quand même mon instinct me
dit qu'elle allait prendre et le
meilleur coup et mon instant il est très
très bon les gars
à votre place je
confirai à mon instant
non ça a l'air logique
c'est pas mal ça force un petit peu une
décision sur l'option aussi généralement
cette position on mange en fait
souvent on mange les Noirs après ils ont
des cases ici mais moi j'ai aussi ce
pion faible tout le temps genre
B3 pour là le TAC ici mais les pièces
différemment pour cette pulsion
que je connais donc
il est souvent en a trois
c'est ma version on va être mon foot
pour jouer contre la tour et rentrer
éventuellement sur ces cases là et mon
cavalier il est ici pour après un
morceau de cavalier souvent
et même des fois qu'elle valait la
cavaler là pour venir en C5 sur
placement de pièces il est bizarre et tu
sais pas trop où on les pièces parce que
le fou un des deux ben voilà
et le cavalor à trois l'idéal serait un
carrément sur 5
mais c'est un peu long qu'elle va
essayer de cavaler B4 cavalier 3 c'est
dans mon cas
donc
[Musique]
OK
que s'est-il passé on s'est arrêté un
truc comme ça donc on partait bien avant
A3
il l'a mis très très vite
là-bas c'était bizarre même nous on sait
pas trop uniquement
on a parlé un peu des idées mais en fait
il a jamais fait liste des qu'on avait
dit
c'est pour venir après en C4 et viser le
centre mais bon il est toujours pas beau
le cavaliers donc c'est un plan assez
bizarre on pensait qu'il avait une idée
dans la tête mais là il prend beaucoup
de temps pour réfléchir donc on sait pas
si
vraiment c'est un truc travail ou pas
Dame des 7 qui avait les Français 4 mais
il va se venger sur le pion E4 donc le
pion 4 qui est perdu mais si tu n'aimes
pas le purinaire en fait
si tu bouges ton cavalier il y a un gros
problème sur la pièce là et B3 tout à
l'heure on avait dit que c'était un coup
qu'on pouvait pas avoir du tout parce
que tout s'ouvrait et là j'ai du
cavalier 5 du fouet 6
ça semble pas terrible
et en plus tactiquement j'ai peut-être
même Tourcoing ces quatre
donc E4 pour rendre donc rendre le pion
et sur dame prend le 4 ça va partir il y
a une fois à 5 G5 donc là c'est une
position intéressante parce qu'on va
bien sûrement changer 5 et en fait les
Noirs vont avoir une majorité trois
contre deux ici avec un pion qui est
déjà passé en E
pendant que les Blancs ont deux
contraintes ce côté là mais les pions
qui sont durs à pousser parce que je me
vois derrière et en plus il y a un poney
donc je sais pas trop ce qui passe j'ai
envie de donner comme un manager
avantage noir dans la position grâce au
Pione
qui peut peut-être
[Musique]
donner un peu de l'eau mais bon après
est-ce que ça va être surtout pour
gagner ça c'est encore une autre
question mais les Noirs ont l'air quand
même mieux
surtout qu'en plus c'est comme du mal à
les pièces dans le sens que si je dois
améliorer ma pièce par exemple
là si je veux bouger mes pieds moi je
fais un truc comme ça si je veux par
exemple
bouger ma tour je peux pas en cavalier
si je bouge mon cavalier il faut penser
calculer le temps suivi de Tour Eiffel
enfin il y a plein de choses à calculer
si je joue B3 pour bouger
ma tour j'ai souvent du foyer F6 et le
CASE noir sont déjà ouvertes
en fait c'est en pratique j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu plus dur
pour les Noirs enfin pour les blancs
placer des pièces mais j'imagine que la
potion quand même reste égale mais faut
être précis que les gens
donc moi je vais parier sur 1-0
c'est pas bien
c'est mieux que moi on va dire je suis
pas sûr qu'il gagne mais je pense que
guéri est un peu mieux
mais bon de la gagner il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire je
vois pas un gain de guéri non plus moi
je dirais nul mais
mais voilà
non c'est pas de poubelle
du tout
et après je ferai ça
ouais
[Musique]
il s'est passé encore une fois tout ce
qu'on vous a prédit
et franchement on est les meilleurs
tatoueurs
pour venir garder ces petites filles en
C4 mais B5 créer des faiblesses sur la
structure et on voit arriver bien sûr à
4 sur la prison A4 je prends C4 et il y
a tout qui est un peu en prise et puis
en a sont tous les deux faibles en
dessin qui est très fort
il y a toujours des découvertes mais
pour l'instant malheureusement j'ai pas
de découverte un cavalier F6 sur Adam
point F6 c'est chez plus de je sais plus
la tour prendre
l'alignement fait peur
mais ce qui nous dérange qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire de nos petits pions j'ai plein
de problèmes en fait c'est le problème
de mes pièces qui sont pas bien sorties
des pions qui sont faibles et j'ai aussi
une menace
tu vois j'ai une position qui est
la jauge elle dit tout va bien
mais en pratique je trouve que c'est une
horreur pour la noire
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué à jouer
côté noir que côté blanc
je pense que
contre un jour de mon niveau je pars
toujours
avec les Blancs que je gagne
pour moi là je vous dis mon avis je
trouve que les blancs sont beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
mon avis
[Musique]
qui n'est pas stock fish
mais mon avis c'est les Blancs ont un
gros avantage
clairement
là je me ferais beaucoup de soucis avec
mais bon peut-être que tout simplement
je peux peut-être jouer
[Musique]
même fou aussi en fait je mange là quoi
deux fois déjà
au moins ça et en plus le cavalier
très vite tu es très mal
j'ai pensé à faire du Fou aussi et
d'imbécis
du style faut aussi prise front pour
faire chaque
au pire je prends de la tour et en fait
enfin
[Musique]
mais bon
même si tu me fais ça et chaque enfin ça
va quoi
cette pollution c'est très très dur pour
les dents ce pion il va être perdu un
moment ou un autre je vais empêcher de
mettre du couloir
c'est malin trop dur
possible sur Magnus oui on peut aller en
Magnus on a déjà vu il y a deux secondes
pour venir très rapidement c'était la
position de
Maroc ou le jeu est lent H3
je crois
toujours pas parce que il y a toujours
ce problème de 4
mais on peut préparer mais je crois
peut-être j'ai quatre parce que j'ai
quatre que c'est possible maintenant
maintenant que le centre un peu
stabilisé si je fais j'ai 4 h je prends
h 30 peut-être que je peux
transférer mes pièces sur la recherche
mais bon le problème de G4 c'est qu'un
moment donné il a reprises et des cinq
en fait à toute il va s'ouvrir et ton
roi il a un peu faible et même souvent
des fois tu peux sacrifier un pion avec
le noir pour ouvrir le jeu
donc
H3 G4 le plan de charcut
j'aime pas du tout désolé chartu encore
[Rires]
non j'ai 4 c'est c'est pas trop trop le
but de la variante normalement parce que
parce que Ben le fou en B7 qui est trop
fort et en fait tu vas faire ça tu vas
te préparer tu vas faire des
c'est pas toujours le bon coup
en tout cas j'ai 4 ans je pense c'est
pas le plan souvent on joue plutôt de ce
côté-là
boum
moi si je joue contre charcut je vais
d'abord attendre
il va pas résister et le jour il le fait
parfois je ferai les 5 mais là c'est bon
il respecte plus son adversaire il se
dit pas qu'il va quand même et donc il
fait descendre tout de suite alors déjà
tout de suite on peut vérifier un peu ce
qui se passe généralement on prépare un
peu plus
mais généralement les Blancs ont plus de
de
menaces sur la dame alors concrètement
que se passe-t-il si je prends juste tu
prends et si je prends tu prends
cette position à cette thématique mais
si tu prends là ce que j'ai pu assister
je sais pas comment je le prends si je
prends maintenant
je cherche des idées je fais attaquer
moi je peux pas est-ce que j'arrive ou
pas
en fait on voit qu'il y a des problèmes
enfin la diagonale un peu fragile
même temps
il y a un problème chez le lent il y a
pas de pression
je m'en fous
pas tactique
mais bon sur le long terme j'ai quand
même des pièces très bien placées
[Musique]
il faut prendre des cinq
ah excuse-moi oui effectivement
[Musique]
comme ça
si je fais ça d'abord
à ce moment-là peut-être que c'est mieux
et si je mange une pièce il faut que je
récupère la pièce quand même
donc là dans cette pollution non je suis
pas d'accord là oui peut-être mais bon
là il faut encore calculer qu'elle va
ici j'aime pas trop cavalier
[Musique]
parce que l'idée
je suis très content j'ai la part de fou
qui va taper tous ces temps-là avec le
passé ça va être cool mais si tu me
prends de 5 il y a pas de fourchette il
y a pas de trucs comme ça
ça peut aller mais bon il y a plein de
choses faut calculer
ces quatre si tu manges de la cavalier
il va y avoir ici un problème
compliqué en tout cas personne n'y veut
ça il cherche des complications
ça c'est trop fort
je suis trop fort
je suis content parce que
j'avais dit
encore une fois
c'est tout ce qui va se passer sauf le
résultat
mais par contre pour trouver tous les
coups
pas de souci
que j'avais donné avec
longtemps
là c'est une partie marrante on dirait
une partie de dames
ils ont bougé tout leur pion
en tout cas Carolin il a bougé tous ses
pions on est on est au 23e coup il a
bougé tous ses pions avec les noirs
et les blancs enfin il y a eu combien de
coups de pions de côté c'est un truc de
ouf
depuis le début
c'est incroyable
encore un
[Musique]
non
alors
2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
coups de pions en 23 coups c'est normal
ça c'est une évidence et après il y aura
plein de rupture
sur à base F5
si tu prends
j'imagine que tu manges du pion
ou pas
je suis pas sûr que ton plan vraiment ce
soit
mais j'ai du mal à y croire
parce que
envie d'ouvrir la position tu vois le
roi noir et tous les pions il a pas
forcément de rock c'est la position est
fermée ça va être plus facile à jouer
pour la noire
moi je suis en train d'ouvrir la
position genre ça ça et ça un truc comme
ça
donc 8 coups de pions consécutier depuis
le 16e coup pendant les 16 premiers
coups on a quand même sorti toutes ces
pièces ah oui non mais là c'est un peu
comme si
c'est un peu comme s'il a commencé à la
partie eux-mêmes
et à partir du 16e coup
et ben c'était
charcuté la place des deux joueurs et
qui s'amusait à la maison en faisant des
coups et tu vois il a fait G5 il a fait
la poussette purge l'autre pion là-bas
enfin c'est un peu du n'importe quoi
[Musique]
si je vous donne cette position là
c'était quoi déjà c'était bon
qu'il y avait les F6
C4
à 6 j'ai vu et sur G3
et
si je vous demande
dans le chat
la moyenne et l'eau des joueurs cette
partie
à combien vous estimez la moyenne et
l'eau de ses joueurs
essayez de pas de pas penser à ce que
et ça ça bon j'ai tranquille mais H3
mais H3 ça a du sens parce que bon
souvent tu veux que H5 sur H4 ça a du
sens
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
mais ça ça m'arrêtiste
ouais faites comme si tu as pas entendu
c'était deux mettre internationaux de
mettre donc avec blanc c'est un joueur
qui a 23 50
[Musique]
histoire
car mathiasi avec les avec les Noirs
effectivement à Kevin Thériault
salut
françois-5 et je suis rasé il est connu
pour sa créativité
Ricard il aurait pu aussi alors même
style très très créatif et des fois
très borderline même pire que borderline
même
pour l'histoire il a il a eu dans sa vie
il a une dizaine de normes de grand-mère
et il a eu comme hello 2499
il était à devenir grand maître
et
d'ailleurs il était même à une partie
enfin même pas même pas une partie il
était à une poignée de main de devenir
grand maître parce que il veut une
partie une partie du tournoi et en fait
si match nul passé grand maître
et son adversaire lui a proposé nul
et Cameron a refusé la nul pour gagner
la partie et a fini par la perdre et
après la dégringolade en élo qui s'est
faite il aura du pain il a jamais réussi
à repasser 2500 euros et maintenant je
suis rasé il est maître mais il a
2280 lots comme ça
donc 2500 euros les aura plus qu'à
être éternellement maître fiel
t'inquiète pas que si moi je joue une
partie pour passer le mettre internat
avec la version propose nulle et que la
nul ne me fait passer la nuit
tu te jettes sur la main toi
je vais je vais je vais tâcher de
t'arracher la main
on fait du lait
en fait ça dépend ça dépend ça dépend ce
que tu veux faire dans les échec si
[Musique]
objectif c'est de Grand Maître et que tu
sais que tu vas passer mettre
c'est juste tu vois
c'est c'est qu'un premier étape pour
passer grand-mère etc que tu es jeune
que tu as l'ambition etc bon bah je joue
quoi
prends pas la nul enfin on s'en fout
quoi mais quand tu es comme moi tu sais
que tu seras jamais dans l'être et que
tu l'objectif de vie et ben tu prends la
nul ça dépend vraiment tu as 12 ans et
que et que tu as 2400 hello et que tu
joues et tu seras quand je rentre
ne sera pas donc il faut prendre quand
vous êtes tous
donc soyons tous
ont pris à 50 000 dollars à 85
au casino ah oui bon après ok ça raconte
les anecdotes de prix
directement
on ferme le jeu
OK
c'est pas débile
C4 c'est possible je sais de trouver un
truc je sais pas je sais pas
je pense que ça peut être un coup pour
le moment
je sais pas si je peux je descends
12 ans 2003 2004 ça va non oui bah oui
tu as 12 ans et tu as 12 ans de 1399 et
que je te propose nul en fait on s'en
fout quand tu as 13 ans
et 2400 hello enfin mettre tu vas l'être
objectif c'est quand même
donc en fait
[Musique]
on s'en fout enfin tu es pas un point
après à te jeter dessus quoi par contre
quand à mon âge et mes capacités
tu prends
[Rires]
tu prends voilà ah oui à un moment donné
en fait ça dépend mais quand c'est ton
quand c'est ton objectif un peu de ta
carrière d'être international en fait
faut arrêter de
voilà papi
mais moi j'ai fait une croix sur le type
de grand-mère donc
en fait je veux juste passer mettre et
après on verra si je peux monter mes
vélos mais pour l'instant
j'ai pas l'impression en tout cas c'est
quand même
grand maître quand on est trop vieux on
peut tu peux pas mais
il faut déjà avoir le niveau
s'en approcher du titre
oui en fait quand tu commences à l'échec
enfin
disons quand tu commences les échecs tu
as tu as imprimes beaucoup moins quand
tu as un certain âge tu peux pas
progresser aussi vite quand tu as 8 9 10
ans que quand on a 5 ans on voit plus en
fait même 30 enfin c'est déjà un peu
tard donc tu peux devenir grand maître
en combattant bien sûr il y a plein
d'exemples mais c'est beaucoup plus rare
et en plus quand tu as quand tu as déjà
une situation
de vie tu as un travail tu as des choses
bon tu as pas le temps en fait de faire
tout ça c'est pour ça que quand tu es
jeune il faut vraiment aller essayer
d'être le plus fort possible quand tu es
jeune et que t'as pas forcément toutes
ces contraintes familiales et travail et
tout ça et après on verra ce que tu peux
faire mais
comment c'est tard tu peux progresser
faire des bonnes choses ça c'est clair
mais grand maître bon
si vous commencez après après 20 ou 30
ans
être elles sont quand même très très
très très faibles
il y a des cas des joueurs qui ont été
comprend pas mais les choses sont quand
même assez réduites
donc
plus rien à faire à part les échecs
est-ce que tu penses que tu peux créer
suffisamment les échecs pour être grand
maître moi peut-être
encore une fois je sais pas si j'ai le
capacité
intellectuelle ou autre pour être mais
[Musique]
si
demain je gagne au loto
je gagne au loto
je gagne plusieurs millions et ben je
suis d'arrêter de travailler tu es tout
arrêter
et me payer à l'entraîneur et travailler
l'échec et faire que ça bah écoute il y
a des chances que je passe à travers
voilà mais bon là il faut que je
travaille je travaille dans les déchets
je suis entraîneur donc travail des
déchets
une fois que j'ai fini ma journée deux
cours d'échec et ben je vous dis que
j'ai pas envie c'est comme vous je sais
pas imaginons vous avez n'importe quel
métier vous n'allez pas après votre
journée de travail faire des heures sup
pour progresser pour vous former dans ce
que vous faites déjà quoi enfin c'est
juste niveau motivation on a cette vue
et puis en plus ça donne beaucoup de
temps quoi beaucoup de temps un bruit
d'investissement et au final être grand
maître moi c'est ma porte rien enfin je
suis bien content de l'aide mais autant
de travail pour finalement un truc qui
servira pas à grand chose
voilà après bien sûr si j'ai que ça à
faire et ben j'aime comme je vous échec
donc si jamais je devenais millionnaire
d'un coup un jour au lendemain et que je
voulais devenir grand maître je pense
que c'est possible parce que j'ai quand
même actuellement quand même pas mal de
connaissances pas mal de choses je
connais beaucoup de choses je parle pas
de zéro quoi tu vois donc peut-être
c'est possible mais bon je ne gagne pas
l'auto parce que déjà je joue pas au
loto
c'est dommage et à moins qu'il y a
quelqu'un joue pour toi une donation
anonyme de plusieurs millions et ben
d'ailleurs si vous le voulez vous
respectez pas
si vous voulez me remettre
un million d'euros
un million d'euros après même 100000 je
prends un million mais bon si vous
voulez mettre un peu moins je prends
aussi
mais après une donation
vous pouvez me dire aussi si vous voulez
un sympa aussi mais si vous voulez me
remettre vous savez
voilà mais sinon non c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout même devenir grand
maître c'est pas Youtube de vie donc
mais oui j'avais que ça à faire il y a
moyen que je travaille les chèques mais
je travaillerai je pense pas que je
serai en mode try hard parce que les
échecs dans ma vie j'ai quand même j'ai
quand même jamais vraiment trayard comme
un fou les échec jamais travaillé
vraiment les échecs j'ai travaillé par
moment et tout mais jamais vraiment
travailler une routine d'entraînement
tout ça chaque jour j'ai jamais eu ça en
fait jamais fait ça donc voilà
[Musique]
donc je pense pas que ça pour moi
super ça existe alors nous on dit super
grand maître on le dit dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est plus de 2700 comme
ça mais le titre officiel n'existe pas
c'est paramètres mais on peut imaginer
qu'un super grand maître c'est un grand
maître qui a plus de 2007 quoi à peu
près
30 000 30000 francs est-il un vas-y
envoie t'inquiète
on va avoir 30 minutes je te promets que
je prends l'entraîneur
ce sera pas tout
[Musique]
je pense que ça se passe bien
c'est ok
on va voir
[Musique]
mais bon il va ouvrir la position sur
les censures et 5 ans ou si le dessin
c'est pour derrière c'est un truc tout à
l'heure je regarde ce style là
[Musique]
moi je vois bien une ouverture
je pense que les noirs sont ok en fait
c'est pas un bon coup en fait je pense
que
ça est en bouge ta F2 pression ici
ouais mais bon je pense que les noirs
sont ok
je pense que le gars
troisième partie
alors il s'est passé quoi depuis qu'on
s'est arrêté on était arrêté à Madame
Bessette qui a eu le 5 il a pas mangé
des deux
et si tu la prends
je peux plus enfermer quand même
ouf attends j'ai trouvé une idée qui a
l'air pas mal ça
la jauge qui descend j'aime pas ça
bon liste c'est ça
de 4
et l'inverse
mais là je n'aime pas
désolé
pourquoi il n'aime pas
je comprends
[Musique]
c'est un peu leur erreur il y a tout qui
se casse la gueule
[Musique]
non c'est grâce à quelque chose
donc il n'a pas mis il a pas mangé B2
normal et tour c'est un à 5 ok à 5h
B3 il y a aussi foot B4 qui était aussi
peut-être des fois des possibilités pour
venir ici ou même cabane et B4 qui était
aussi jouable pour taper sur le pion
c'est 6
et 3 G4
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici tout
retourne encore
venir en C3 et taper là-dessus ou faire
tour 3 tour B3
je sais pas si c'est possible
B4 direct bonne soirée mala merci d'être
passé en tout cas
si
direct j'ai peur qu'il y ait A4 en fait
j'aime pas ton plan
clic au hasard
[Rires]
j'aime pas ton coup
et alors pourquoi j'aime pas ton coup
parce que les cases blanches sont très
faibles maintenant après à 4 cavaliers 6
je vais rentrer de partout c'est du
gruyère
du gruyère
ça dépend quand même le fromage quand il
est cuit j'aime bien
par exemple sur les pizzas j'aime bien
le fromage par contre si tu me prends
pour compter je sais pas quoi là non
[Musique]
et si les cuit genre tu vois tout ce qui
est raclette tartiflette tout ça je
j'aime beaucoup fondu
parfait
le fromage bien cuit envoyez-moi une
machine à raclette
et des fois même B3 on va jouer un
cavalier des 6 B3 et pas ridicule l'idée
je B3 sauf que là il y aurait deux à
quatre en fait j'aime pas trop le
placement des pièces des blancs la
pression que ils sont pas forcément prêt
à tout ça parce que fouet
pour empêcher cavaler des six mais dans
cette position avec très souvent ça très
souvent on va avoir un G5 suivi de G4 en
fait ça arrive souvent même pas
forcément jouer jouer les cinq surf Wave
4 même là j'ai 5 je pense c'est un coup
qui aurait pu être joué suivi d'âge 5 et
G4 c'est thématique dans ces positions
dès qu'on fait je crois
c'est marrant sa position j'ai reçu une
confession je crois enfin tout est-ce
que tu es au courant de ce que c'est une
confession
non
la vilaine Fatou alors attends je vais
vous expliquer une confession en fait tu
sais que ce tournoi est la marque la
particularité d'avoir une confession
enfin d'avoir des Confessions d'un
professionnel et les joueurs pendant la
partie peuvent se lever et aller dans la
salle du confessionnal et
et ce qu'on fait c'est
et dire ce qu'ils veulent à la caméra
donc des fois par exemple carcennes hier
en sa partie il a dit qu'il avait
blender Dame des 6 contre-sots
peuvent venir oh j'ai raté ça
mais du coup je pense que je suis quand
même bien
les gens peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
et du coup je crois que j'ai des
confessions c'est marrant en fait tu
vois ça coûte un petit truc
là on va pas te voir pendant quelques
secondes je peux m'excuser au prix du
public enfin toi disparu
aime te voir on va lui en donner du
Fatou
[Musique]
fessionnel professionnel
alors j'ai plein plein alors pris game
on s'en fout j'ai énormément norvégien
je pense c'est intéressant
car c'est une confession
qui a fait une confession
il y a un autre breaking carlten où il y
a deux trucs cartés
ou pas
vraiment mais si je mets un
professionnel tu vois tu comprends
que j'écoute aussi dis-moi je peux pas
écouter mais je peux écouter mais il
faut que je fasse un truc
j'essaye
j'essaie de tout comprendre
ah au pire dans le chat on a pas torche
c'était c'est le jeune homme qui m'avait
accompagné lors des trois premières
journées de tournoi on va lancer ah oui
on est content qu'il soit là donc je
vais lancer le le
[Musique]
ah tu fais pas non regarde excuse-moi
excuse-moi qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
d'accord
c'est bien fait avoir
[Musique]
et tout le monde a compris ça alors je
vais vous montrer que je commence à
télécharger d'avoir le truc et j'en ai
un qui s'appelle breaking Carlson
donc je sais pas dans quel sens c'est
mais j'en ai d'autres cartiennes bah
écoutez ça c'est ça ça m'intéresse et
elle n'a qu'à Moura elle n'a plusieurs
la caméra je crois il vient il fait des
fois
je pense que le stream lui manque envie
de parler quoi si il joue il veut parler
et je vais vous aussi je vais vous
mettre un petit Naka et je vais écouter
en même temps l'astuce pour écouter
Fatou il faut que je me mute
donc je vais quand même je suis curieux
de savoir ce qu'il dit
donc je vous dis à tout de suite on vous
met les confessions
[Musique]
la deuxième
on va laisser la deuxième du coup désolé
je
non je crois non je crois que tu te
trompes ici dans la danse junior je
crois que tu te trompes je crois qu'il
dit qu'il voulait que tu traduise ton
message et on part sur la deuxième vidéo
je pense qu'elle en anglais à tout de
suite
[Musique]
on the screen expertise
Fatou as-tu compris
derrière toi je sais pas si c'est normal
et pas cavalier gf6
car il
comprend pas en fait de quoi il parle
attends on va revenir au début
quand j'ai deux cavaliers qui peuvent
aller sur la même case
et en fait sur chescom il y a marqué que
cavalier F6
et c'est ça sonne
pourquoi il y a un caca ici en fait non
c'est qu'il y avait les gf6 mais en fait
comme l'autre il est cloué il peut pas y
aller donc il a fait un trip sur ça
complètement fou je crois que c'est ce
qu'il a je crois que c'est ce qu'il a
c'est ce qu'il a expliqué dans la vidéo
et
pour ça que je reprenais pas pourquoi il
disait ça en fait mais
mais
voilà oui à cavalier qui avait les DFS
comme c'est un coup illégal tu as pas
besoin de marquer que c'est cavaliers
qui font un F6 tu m'as juste cavalier F6
parce que tu sais que l'autre synchro
mais
voilà bon en fait juste il a voulu trois
ou pas
c'est un petit troll de Cars quoi
donc
[Musique]
tout est mieux voilà
après
je pense qu'il raconte sa vie
il aime bien venir en fait et
attends il aime bien venir Naka
pour
commenter les parties qui se passe à
côté
on écoute d'accord
je vais voir combien de temps elle dure
la vidéo parce que c'est des fois que
Maka
je vais juste ouvrir avec mon VLC juste
essayer de voir combien de temps sont
parce que si elles sont trop longues
je me méfie
4 minutes 30 il est content parce qu'il
arrive
qu'on parte faire une petite pause
et quand guise de pause on leur donne le
petit confessionnal de de maca qui dure
5 minutes ça te dit ou pas
d'accord d'avance pour la traduction
[Rires]
je vais vous mettre je vais vous mettre
bon n'a qu'un il va juste je pense
commenter un peu de son avis sur chaque
position donc restez là en tout cas vous
allez pouvoir voir ça c'est sympa
et nous on revient du 5 minutes qu'on a
encore fini de parler
à tout de suite
[Musique]
j'ai une bonne nouvelle je suis resté là
donc je vais pouvoir vous traduire un
peu ce qui s'est passé alors de toutes
ces conseils très loin
mais voilà en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que knaka est venu donner un peu
son avis sur toutes les positions sauf
qu'il est il a donné son avis sur la
position de départ enfin de assez tôt
dans la partie après il revient dans la
deuxième vidéo pour rechanger son avis
donc dans la partie de Magnus dit qu'une
partie que alors il disait au début que
dans la partie de Magnus que le temps
prend des quatre enfin le cavalier prend
était bizarre mais en fait pour
contrôler le temps etc et il pense que
la pollution elle est OK pour les Noirs
c'est les positions comme Magnus m ou
Magnus va pouvoir peut-être essayer de
pousser un peu la pollution vu que c'est
déjà plus ou moins égalité
c'est une partie où il pensait que ça
allait faire nul assez vite à moins que
gookesh avait une idée dans l'ouverture
pour essayer de faire quelque chose mais
bon là vu la position encore on pense
que ça va faire nul assez rapidement
une partie ou qui était assez équilibré
mais après quand il est revenu sur la
partie dans les GB2 il disait que les
Blancs étaient pas mal quand même avec
un peu tout ce qu'on avait dit dans la
position
Abdou et karwana il dit c'était une
rencontre très intéressante parce qu'en
fait les deux joueurs ont été entraînés
par Kassim quasiment
attends
du monde
et donc il a travaillé avec Faby pendant
très longtemps et maintenant et ben il
travaille avec Abdou
et donc
voilà pourra travailler avec lui donc
une partie arbres intéressant de voir
vis-à-vis de tout ça et je me souviens
plus il apparaît de l'ouverture
en fait j'écoutais partiellement mais là
je sais plus ce qu'il a dit sur ça et ce
sont ça partis au début il disait que
partie normale qu'il avait travaillé
cette ligne il y a quelques semaines
et il disait que
il trouvait que quelques alliésa était
pas forcément très bien préparé dans ce
tournoi enfin tu vas pas spécialement
bien préparé
et il pense que pour être au top niveau
il devrait travailler un peu plus
ces ouvertures c'est ce qu'il a dit et
il a parlé de plantes etc et il a dit
que la partie pouvait prendre n'importe
quel tournure mais en général il
trouvait qu'il était dans ses parties
pas que dans celle-là mais bon c'est
parti il était pas forcément très bien
préparé
ensuite il a revu sur la partie et je
sais plus ce qu'il a dit
il est revenu à les gens qui
s'ennuyaient
parce que je m'ennuie donc du coup bah
voilà en fait voilà il est en string il
est là il est content d'être là en tout
cas Nakamura et c'est un peu c'est un
peu l'impression qu'on a mais la partie
enfin les positions sont toutes après
normal et pour l'instant rien de décider
en tout cas dans aucune des parties
qu'on peut avoir
ici voilà Fatou
je sais je t'ai vu
je reste là pour vous et
[Musique]
le stream des noms bugs ah oui j'ai pas
changé la j'ai pas changé alors oui
c'est moi merci beaucoup FG comme un fil
rouge là il faudrait que je mette cette
scène là et là tu auras le vrai nom
c'est ma faute je suis responsable
désolé je ne me prépare d'une nouvelle
ouverture à quelques jours semaine
non mais en fait disons que c'est même
pas forcément synthétique c'est que
Fiero a perdu beaucoup beaucoup de temps
dans l'ouverture
et avec les blancs au bout de
10 coups déjà il est resté plus qu'une
heure à la pendule quoi c'est vrai qu'à
ce niveau là c'est un peu bizarre mais
bon en plus la cadence je vous rappelle
c'est deux heures deux heures ko avec un
rajout de temps de 10 secondes par coup
à partir du 40e c'est à dire que pour
l'instant firu et Naka sont au 19e coup
et si on roi des pensées déjà trois
cartes son temps alors que le reste
c'est du chaos ou quoi
comment normalement on peut pas se
permettre ça ah ça va se terminer ça va
se terminer en Bullet cette partie en
tout cas pour fille
donc il y a eu à 5 il y a eu B4 tout à
l'heure dans le chat on nous a demandé
alors je sais plus que c'était
si on pouvait jouer P4
et après ce B4 on est parti dans un
débat de si jamais le fromage dans le
fromage
et
au final moi j'avais dit j'avais dit que
j'aimais pas du tout B4 parce que ça
donne des cases deux partout et voilà
donc il y a plein de trous on parle de
gruyère etc c'est toi qui est au hasard
voilà bah tu vois tu prends bien ton nom
pourra proposer des quatre mais ça a été
le parfait donc bah écoute je sais pas
quoi te dire j'aimais pas je trouvais ça
moche et je trouve toujours ça moche et
ça a été joué alors qu'elle peut être B4
parce que
il y a eu fou F4 derrière
à 3
c'était content
sinon t'empêche la pousser ses six
potentiel alors
ok en fait c'est intéressant ce qu'il
fait d'un point de vue pratique
B4 va bien avec fue F4
uniquement foie F4 je pense que le 4
c'est peut-être le coup quasiment
obligatoire ici pourquoi si les blancs
je vois pas fou F4 les Noirs vont jouer
cavaler des 6 cavaler ces quatre et là
il y a des problèmes sur un peu tout ta
structure et là l'idée 4 maintenant si
tu verras là ben écoute je mange
qu'est-ce qu'il veut et si jamais il y a
eu à trois je mange maintenant tu as la
paire de fou
contre la perte de cavaliers les fous
sont forts dans les positions ouvertes
les carrés sont forts dans la potion
fermée
là les fous peuvent jouer mais c'est pas
non plus énorme
encore être un peu actifs mais ça reste
quand même pas génial quoi et si
j'arrive ici à mettre un câble genre en
Détroit ou en C5 tu vois et ben je vais
peut-être que je peux progresser et
taper sur le pion C6 qui a un pion au
final arriéré donc en fait sur le long
terme ça intéressant ce qu'il fait parce
qu'il y a une faiblesse qui va être à
vie ici et j'ai des cases intéressantes
pour les blancs donc dans cette
pollution on peut imaginer que les
cavaliers peuvent être plus être plus
fort que les fous
parce que
[Musique]
il y avait baisse qui était qui sont ici
mais c'est toujours circulaire ce
cavalier arrive en C4 surtout après
avoir joué à trois franchement la
position les stratégiquement pas
terrible pour les pour les pour les
blancs mais c'est l'idée donc en fait si
tu joues B4 pour je ferai là on va voir
ça dépend
elle est un peu primo le prix move de
filou
on s'en va
il fait tout ce que je dis pas
il a vu qu'avant ouais mais en fait bon
c'est logique encore ce qu'il dit hein
mais c'est vrai qu'un échange de fou
contre cavalier n'est pas débile hein
parce que tu penses que tu peux lutter
contre la contre la C5 et le pion C6
arrière et les cavaliers peut-être plus
fort mais je pense que sur le long terme
ça va être pris ça
ça va être ça va être pris
c'est pas pour jeter des fleurs touffes
non il donne -05 si B4 n'est pas celui
du F4 tout de suite
ça m'a l'air logique regarde je vais
leur dire
c'est le deuxième coup de l'ordi tout
retour numéro 1 c'était mon idée de
retour et oui ça ou ça je l'avais dit Tu
es mon idée
là je P4 plutôt sur un 4 et vous pouvez
faire obliger
faut F4
mais maintenant sur ça
ça se joue pas grand chose les deux
coups sont très bons pour les blancs
apparemment ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait
[Musique]
qu'il a fait pas super à tout à l'heure
j'avais parlé de GSM G4 j'en avais parlé
c'était le bon coup ici apparemment si
je bouge mon fou
je vais parler d'âge 5 fois 4
c'est pas mal pour les Noirs enfin c'est
comme ça qu'on joue généralement ce
policier là
on avait parlé encore
en fait je suis plus fort que les
joueurs
on va arrêter de la poser
alors qu'un vélo 3 mais maintenant j'ai
5 à plus trop de sens maintenant c'est
un petit peu cavalier en D6 ça marche
plus trop et à tout moment je peux faire
en là et mettre une tour ici et
doubler etc et taper sur le pion c'est 6
bah écoute Fillon comment c'est pas mal
au final cavalier E4
elle est vraiment caca
je pense qu'il faut que tu bouges ton
fou tu défendre aussi mais c'est moche
faut aussi j'ai peur de ça aussi
suivi de Carice C4 en excuse-moi
je pensais que je pensais que je
commence à fatiguer les gens
il faut plus m'écouter des fois
d'avance ouais ok en fait ça va au
niveau temps surtout siphyrou commence à
le bon coup
et ben la pression c'est vrai que d'un
cas va devoir réfléchir un peu plus et
peut-être passer en dessous
niveau temps c'est possible
c'est vraiment en train de tout de tous
ces changer 11 jours TMI on verra pas te
mettre ça mais ne me
ne me
pose pas par contre j'ai je vous prépare
des belles surprises
sympas qui écrivent d'arriver dans la
foulée pas de métal
ça risque d'être sympa
j'en dis pas plus parce que pas de spoil
quand même
c'est pas bien quand même
non
j'aime bien un petit peu vous mettre un
peu
comment on appelle ça
[Musique]
contre
depuis le début je donnais un bel
avantage ma meilleure offre
mais on va se comprendre pourquoi et ben
il a pas un six croix avantage que ça
moi je donne depuis le début en gros
avantage blanc dans ma 5 c'est bien joué
ça empêche de MP4
prise
h3o6 cavalier ici à chaque plus un arbre
en B4 moi je sais pas pourquoi juste
parce que je vais empêcher des cartes je
suis sûr que l'ordinateur
me comprend non plus ok je suis seul au
monde
donc ici là je vais cavalier F4 est
tombé 8 il veut jouer B4 en fait la
pollution elle était ok pour les Noirs
mais elle faisait peur
parce que je pense qu'il fallait voir
[Musique]
parce que sinon dans cette position si
tu as compris que tu allais à réussir à
faire B4 ça va en fait mais là c'est dur
quand même
ok bah écoute après ça je pense que
c'est égal dans ces trois points pour
clouer on va changer ça compte ça à un
moment donné
peut-être même faire cavalier 5
il faut prendre à chaque fois ça va
faire un nul je pense être tranquille
mon chat il va bien oui rapidement
que mon câble soit assez long par contre
je pense pas que vous allez la voir mais
elle dort à côté de moi
je le mets son petit
litre
par rapport au truc est-ce que vous la
voyez
vous la voyez ou pas le chat
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait à chaque fois que
qu'elle vient ne mange les câbles et me
casse les pieds pour être poli et ben je
la prends je la mets sur le lit avec son
enfin je lui mets son lit et je la mets
ici et elle dort généralement
elle accepte elle accepte
elle accepte son destin
c'est ça c'est ça
en fait quand je suis tout seul à la
maison avec elle et ben
je la laisse rentrer avec moi là où je
suis sinon je ferme la porte si je suis
pas tout seul parce que
c'est difficile
il y a trop de trop de choses à la
maison elle est trop elle adore en fait
elle peut pas rester toute seule
genre
ça va mieux ça va ça va défoncer la
porte
l'autre partie intéressante les choses
qui sont passées depuis
alors tari carton pas mal de choses
alors
à mon chat aussi
de ça
je la preuve j'ai une preuve mais bon
pas envie de la chercher mais oui moi de
partir
[Musique]
alors il y a eu ça ce qu'on avait dit
aussi
une belle et pas là parce qu'il a pas
été tout simplement
il a pas été invité en ce moment il y a
tellement de joueurs de l'élite en fait
[Musique]
bien solide pour les blancs
les noirs sont actifs
faire attention que la tour en a deux
elle est plus sur la viande rangée des
fois il paiera des petites blagues tout
revu qui peuvent aussi arriver ça peut
être pas simple mais fou c'est 3
[Musique]
compliqué bon Segal mais ça joue
c'est cool c'est que Paris il est en
avance en temps donc apparemment pour
l'instant ça va il est pas vraiment sous
la pression du temps qu'on aurait pu
penser de le parti elle est pas mal
réfléchi au début
il a tout décliné aussi il a Chartres
c'est vrai qu'il a peut-être décliner
pour ça mais après
je sais pas ce qu'il paye le mieux
mais oui peut-être qu'il a juste il
avait un accord avec son club et qui lui
a joué en Top 16 c'est
3 et écoute
les joueurs français au Top 16 plutôt
que
dans un autre pays
ouais bah après chaque joueur cherche un
petit peu aussi son son avantage sanguin
quoi bien sûr donc oui bah après il est
payé pour jouer à pour jouer à Asnières
c'est clair
après peut-être après aussi tu as tu
vois tu interclub c'est un peu
c'est spécial quoi tu vois
quand tu donnes ton accord tu me dis que
tu joues etc
après je peux comprendre moi aussi il y
a des gros gains donc on sait pas ce
qu'elle était contacté ou pas on sait
pas ce qu'il a il a été invité
c'est que les français pour l'instant il
y a le Top 16 c'est vraiment le la
compétition de l'année pour pour les
clubs on a été une Bacro aussi on en
aura précisé qui sont au top 16
et donc ça fate il y a aussi jus de
Moussa on a vu d'ailleurs Jules qui a
fait nul contre Kevin Kevin thérieux une
belle nulle bien battue
pour l'instant
j'ai vu une photo de lui alors un et sur
son chevalet il y a un G j'ai de grand
maître
du coup je vais commander sur Facebook
je le dis mais pourquoi tu as un jeu
il va pas répondre mais bon il est en
tournoi on va dire mais ça compagne m'a
répondu
[Musique]
et il a jamais lu hello pour passer
grand maître c'est un peu comme moi sauf
qu'il a moins de l'or enfin par rapport
à son objectif
2500 euros pour être grand maître et il
est pas loin quand même 24 50
mais bon voilà Kevin si vraiment il
travaille les échecs et il pourrait
facilement mais c'est un peu le même
problème que moi en fait tu fais déjà
beaucoup d'échecs dans la journée avec
tes cours et tout derrière travail pour
toi-même même faire les tournois c'est
difficile
quand tu as des enfants c'est le
problème c'est un problème
et puis les échecs
si t'as pas le temps et oui
le deuxième qui est en route et qui
d'ailleurs arrivait très très bientôt je
crois je suis
je crois que c'est prévu pour l'été je
crois juillet-août
il me semble
tu sais tout je suis au courant de tout
tu veux savoir la vie de Kevin tu
m'appelles tu prends rendez-vous et on
en parle ça marche
[Musique]
comme ça comme je sais pas trop où je
vais là peut-être là j'aime bien il peut
y avoir des trucs ici
et toi tu passes sur non plus vous voyez
parce qu'après ça il y a des thèmes de
Manu couleur maintenant
donc pour 8 ça va faire
attention quoi et ça ça
c'est une potion qui est à la régale à
la structure est symétrique et tout
mais incroyable de pièces et je pense
qu'il peut avoir des problèmes tactiques
arrivent qui peuvent arriver vite quoi
et je pense c'est une position que
Magnus peut gagner quoi
je pense que ça autant que ça peut ça
peut se gagner dans le monde de temps
en fait je pense
c'est un truc qui peut arnaquer mais
c'est un truc qui qui joue quoi parce
que ça reste actif tu vois il y a du lac
et des trois bon il faut prendre mais tu
sens qu'il y a des petits thèmes des 6
qui va être joué
et là j'aime bien mettre un faux F1
peut-être par exemple
je sais pas s'il y a une tactique après
faut faire je crois pas histoire de
ramener un peu le fou mettre le cavalier
de faire des choses
je pense que les Blancs veulent
stabiliser alors qu'avait là échanger 3
tu vois je pense tu es un peu cette
stabiliser la position
mais il faut les fins j'aime bien ce
coup en plus il y a pas d'échec sur la
première rangée c'est
quoi ce lien
[Musique]
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous savez ce qui
s'est passé en 2009
en 2009 kevin est passé je crois qu'il
est passé maître en 2009 d'ailleurs il
avait 2449 qui viennent il y avait un
gros hello mais malheureusement pour lui
il a fait face à un stouffe qui avait
[Musique]
et
et depuis Kevin n'arrive pas à dormir et
en plus c'était une bonne partie que
j'avais fait et Kevin il avait été très
cool on avait analysé un peu on avait
parlé la partie là qui est très sympa je
regarde un bon souvenir
pas que pour la victoire mais même des
fois après une défaite tu peux voir il y
a des joueurs qui prennent plus ou moins
bien les
défaites quoi et Kevin très sympa
franchement j'avais déjà eu un très bon
feeling après la partie en fait
donc
c'est quelqu'un de bien
il faut Clipper pour lui mettre ça
colonies ce qui fait dans les échecs que
pour sa sympathie donc oui
et le pire voilà en plus c'est vrai que
pour la servante il a fait une vidéo
YouTube en montrant et commentant la
partie qu'on avait joué ensemble en 2009
tout ça avant le match de Blitz qu'on
avait fait sortir comme en disant cette
fois-ci je prendrai ma revanche
sauf qu'il a perdu le match
[Rires]
il a perdu le match contre tous enfin un
moment donné bon je sais plus quoi faire
mais
bon on se rejoint en fait l'année
prochaine
cette partie je
veux pas me ridiculiser en vrai les
blancs et si c'est Kevin en face tant
mieux
problème de couchauffe non je suis bien
là
mon Obs il me dit que je suis très bien
non non je suis à 100% à charcut je
crois que c'est toi problème
toi le problème ok alors on a toujours
pas de partie qui sont terminées tout se
passe bien ok ça va très bientôt se
terminer alors attends Google
moi je pense pas avoir 16 ans je suis
pas sûr
Google
et leur faire attention parce qu'au
final ben c'est un peu plus avec les
Blancs même si le pion H2 peut tomber si
j'arrive à manger à 6 j'ai quand même
deux pions passés contre un seul Angers
donc il est parti manger le pion
mais le pion quand même bien avancé on
peut imaginer
une pièce qui va s'échanger alors sur ça
peut-être qu'il y a foule ici faire
attention
qui peut clouer
il faut être très précis
et ça ça et là tu vas perdre
tu vas perdre avec les Noirs ça peut
être tendu mais pas il faut juste pas
faire j'ai trois à la fois 5 attaque B2
j'ai 3 qui arrive
je pense ça va être nul assez facilement
15 ans et demi oui en ce genre de 2009
nous donc il était ami pas longtemps
on sait jouer quand c'était quoi c'était
c'était en quel mois c'était
allez blanc et à une bonne partie depuis
quelques coups je me faisais un peu tout
de suite tout à l'heure mais il a réussi
à trouver le super B4 de clic au hasard
qui m'avait l'air pas bon du tout mais
en fait au final avec la suite de coupe
que les raisins à trouver il parle on a
l'impression qu'il a quand même un bon
avantage ici on peut imaginer un tour C2
pour eux c'est deux et taper peut-être
sur E6 sur C6 pardon mais dès que je
joue sur ces deux lors d'un temps n'aime
pas
mais c'est un coup qui a l'air standard
mais il y a aussi un coup j'aimerais
bien faire ce matin
ce cavaler E1
c'est totalement en cours on se dirige
là depuis E6 enfin depuis pendant ces
quatre je tape sur 6 je tape sur A4 et
mon cavalier
et après je peux toujours doubler tout
et essayer au fur et à mesure de manger
6 surtout que le camel en F3
et c'est vrai que ce cavalier ben on
pourrait l'améliorer quoi
pour l'améliorer et en fait là m'a l'air
pas mal du tout et il a pas ajouté à la
fin de la partie
cavallois c'est pas du tout un coup
proposé d'ailleurs par la jauge
et la chose qui descend
et pourtant c'est un coup
il joue il joue ça ah il passe par là
ouais bon ok ça me dépasse mais je
comprends
je comprends je comprends
ok bon en tout cas c'est ça reste une
position difficile pour pour les
carreaux et Caro qui a qui a la perte de
fou mais mes positions fermées et c'est
la pression était ouverte ça pourrait
être très très bon pour pour les Noirs
mais malheureusement position est trop
trop
je pense qu'il peut il peut la gagner
celle-là
je pense qu'il peut la gagner cette
partie très bien livraison
Google
on a la partie de saut ça va faire mieux
aussi je pense très vite un soir on est
ici
soit on est ici il y a eu 5 3 4 pour
chacun il y a ce plan qui est faible qui
est faible et aussi des problèmes sur le
pion E5 et il y a trop de problèmes de
perpétuel
[Musique]
tout le reste j'ai la caméra que vous
avez sur le sur les sur le l'écran j'ai
que ça
si vous voulez une belle caméra bien
bonne
c'est la caméra de
la table donc de Magnus
on va voir après
tu peux le voir sur le
site de la Fédération je crois
tu vas sur
tu vas tu fais des échecs sur Google
et tu as un lien où tu as aussi ouais je
suis bête
je suis bête est parti mais sinon tu vas
chercher de la fédé dans tous les
résultats et les parties aussi tu as un
lien qui t'amène en partie
par contre vous n'avez pas sur le twitch
là-bas vous restez chez nous
aujourd'hui et oui le 5 a été joué
merci pour le lien ciel bleu
Chartres voilà il y a plein de trucs il
y a plein de sites merci à tous donc le
5 qu'est-ce qu'on joue avec les Noirs
enfin tout cas toujours pas
je ne sais pas en fait je sais pas ce
que je joue
je réfléchis
4 non
j'ai vu les 10 premiers coups
et je pense aussi à tour B3 en disant
que si tu bouges je peux manger là
et donc je sais pas ce que tu faisais là
dangereux donc j'étais pas sûr mais je
pense que ça fait nul direct mesdames
ben écoute ça ça fait une menace
parce que c'est une menace d'ailleurs
ou je peux pas passer ah ça fait nul
direct en fait
ok ça fait nul si je monte mon roi je
perds la dame avec un clouage d'accord
donc je vais revenir ici on va refaire
mieux et c'est la répétition
c'est fort possible Fatou que ça se
termine comme ça en fait
c'est fort probable
je vois pas comment il peut la jouer ici
son roi est faible il a aucun échec
il y a enfin passé noir ici il a aucun
aucune chance de gagner là il va faire
mieux je peux à peu près dire que ça va
faire ça à partir
je viens de voir
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y aura pas il y aura pas
d'apprendre à 5 que j'ai pas vu comme ça
par
ouais mais tout ça en fait c'est
bricolage quoi
en fait
concrètement il se passe quoi je ne sais
pas
bizarre
je fais la même non
même ça enfin franchement tu gagnes pas
ça avec les Blancs
je suis pas sûr mais je pense qu'il
vient pas
[Musique]
tu prends de la dame je crois là
je pense qu'il va y avoir nul je pense
je pense à faire nul
4 contre
[Musique]
3 mais c'est un peu détaché quoi c'est
pas le cas de contrôle non mais ça sent
plus de la jouer dans cette position
[Musique]
là je pense que bon ça a l'air quand
même assez drôle
et donc Nakamura ça a changé des pièces
la caméra
et je pense que les échanges favorise
quand même les blancs
parce qu'au final tu auras du mal à
défendre toutes les pions
ça me l'associe ça et ça ça te propose
de faire tourner
ok bon ici firou est très bien
c'est pour lui je pense il va tomber à
la langue
deux fois comme nationale
[Musique]
assez correct
est-ce qu'on sait ce qui était le fait à
tout repéré par le chat et stuff oui
je pense que je sais ouais
un tournoi que j'avais
commenté c'était le championat du monde
de
la chasse random
[Musique]
et je crois que c'est bien ça oui si
elle le
c'était je crois que c'était elle
c'est une Iranienne je crois
d'origine il me semble
et elle habite en Angleterre
comment
suspendu par la suite parce qu'en fait
je crois qu'elle avait
soutenu publiquement alors je sais plus
ce que c'était alors c'était
[Musique]
peut-être que c'est de nous en parler je
sais plus où c'était
[Musique]
avec une jupe jaune et un haut bleu
en soutien je pense avec Rennes il y a
plein de publics comme ça qui en soi par
un problème mais par rapport après quand
tu fais un tournoi et tout je crois
qu'il faut être neutre il y avait ça il
y avait aussi un truc aussi par rapport
à du féminisme ou je sais plus trop quoi
ouais dans votre chat s'il avait donc
voilà il y avait il y avait des trucs
mais après je sais plus comment ça c'est
fait mais je l'ai il y avait je sais pas
trop elle avait elle avait un t-shirt je
sais plus ce qu'il y avait ce son
t-shirt et on lui avait dit que c'était
pas approprié qu'il fallait qu'elle soit
qu'elle se change et elle a dit elle a
dit ok quand tu es revenu
mais je sais plus ce que c'était mais là
je vais faire des bêtises ciel bleu à
l'air d'être
alors après on a pu rentrer en Iran à
cause d'une photos sans voile dans les
cheveux elle a porté un t-shirt woman
freedom OK
que la fille OK
ouais c'est un truc comme ça il y avait
un truc tu vois
je savais qu'il y avait un truc de je
suis là mais je sais plus quoi faire
tout le monde mais
[Musique]
moi je comprends les deux mais bon
on change les pieds un problème sur long
terme sur le pion le pion de B4 des
blancs attention on va devoir manger
après la prise ca va les prendre on va
voir surtout sûrement fou à 5 de bien
défendre ce petit ce petit pion de 4
enfin tout
déconnecté
mais c'est bon
ils l'ont fait venir arbitrer alors
qu'elle était suspendu par la file donc
c'est vrai que c'est sympa
[Musique]
sympa bon petit message en tout cas de
la part c'est cool
ok à suivre là il se passe pas grand
chose là Fatou
ça c'est la partie actuelle il y a autre
chose j'ai eu d'autres coups passés
oui
ok alors là il y a eu un petit peu de
comment qu'est-ce qu'on ferait sans toi
et franchement je me le demande et le
mieux c'est qu'on se pose pas la
question Fatou
ça va bien se passer je serai toujours
là
en espérant que
5 tours
jeu avec tout ré 8 et qui avait le 6 on
va lui dire le 3
il y a eu dame D6 il change de pièce OK
moi je vois bien fourant cette arrivée
et essayer de
liquider un peu la position
mais bon la position elle peut devenir
pas mal pour pour les Noirs si
les pièces qui changent trop parce que
enfin à trop vouloir essayer de faire
nul ça peut je regarde des fois contre
Ariane tari tu vois là on a une
structure avec tous les points sur blanc
le fou il est hyper solide alors que là
toi aussi tu es tout sur blanc donc
c'est plus faible et la tour elle est
active tu as le temps de dire un petit
peu
un petit peu en prise je pense que le
roi blanc est moins en sécurité que le
roi noir
ça reste grosso modo égal mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même plus
facile pour les noirs
je préfère la potion de Magnus je pense
qu'il y a des
petites position qui peut être une
pression de travail Fatou
il faut bidouiller même quand on voit
pas trop de
trop de choses à faire lui il en trouve
ouais après c'est une position il y a
plus beaucoup de pièces donc jouer pour
jouer des fois tu peux juste pas trop
améliorer la position
mais je commence enfin je trouve que sa
position est tellement solide en fait
et qu'il y a potentiel problème chez les
Blancs je me dis que ça peut être un bon
signal aussi pour le noir
mais ok objectivement c'est égal
l'objectif
c'est il y a pas grand chose à faire
quoi
et je sais pas peut-être fou de tomber
un et se replacer
4 c'est un couple
et si tu prends là je prends un F7 mais
donc nous on met après changer les
pièces c'est ça va être un réflexe aussi
on veut essayer de faire nul j'imagine
qu'il veut c'est de faire nul Ariane
et donc généralement on joue un peu
serré quand on joue contre la
on essaie de ne pas perdre
mais tu vois la potion du roi blanc est
toujours un petit peu faible donc c'est
pour ça qu'il est toujours un petit peu
de jeu et un petit peu de choses à
regarder à vérifier c'est pas ça reste
pas simple mais ok effectivement c'est
c'est égal sur un bon jeu des deux
joueurs ça va faire du bien
c'est ça me paraît c'est clair en fait
on va voir aussi après son 27e coup ce
soir ouais on est au 27ème coup et il
reste 26 minutes chacun et en fait je
pense que le temps c'est cool plus ça
fait les affaires de Magnus parce qu'au
final
en blitz je pense que ma glisse c'est là
qu'il va réussir peut-être à poser des
problèmes j'aime pas trop ce squash qui
a été joué j'aime pas trop
parce que je me dis que ce plan pour
être faible un jour
par exemple est-ce que je suis objectif
H4 pour toi je pense qu'il voulait
bloquer
peut-être que dans certaines lignes il
voulait empêcher de fou prendre H3 et 3
mais je vois pas là je vois pas trop
vraiment l'explication
là je vois ça moi
pardon
H4 j'ai loué
il est tard ça fait ça fait une semaine
qu'on commence ça tous les jours
des fois je louche
donc ok ce que j'ai un autre moyen mais
c'est plutôt un HK qui peut être faible
sur le long terme
je regardais des trucs je pensais à un
coup qui a pas large génial
mais non mais ok j'aime pas H4 par
principe en fait si tu veux dès que tu
te crées des faiblesses Magnus il va il
va juste te les
[Musique]
comme ça
mais H4 c'est un coup assez responsable
quand même
D8 ça peut toujours arriver puis même
une double menace tout à l'heure j'ai
dit top c'est 5 en pensant attaquer les
deux mais ok tu es très loin dans B4
pour faire un effet tu vois en vrai
je pense que c'est pas forcément
nécessaire même dame j'ai droit tu vois
c'est un pauvre pas forcément nécessaire
en fait
ça te crée cette faiblesse là mais je
sais pas quelle idée en fait
qu'il a il a eu peur que que Magnus dans
une variante qu'il avait calculé face
infopren H3 celui de dame G3 peut-être
que c'était une idée cette dame G3 c'est
tout pour H3 était aussi une idée
possible de Magnus et qu'il a voulu
l'empêcher la cache 4 je pense que
Magnus
je me demande un peu enfin je
m'interroge avec des devoir jouer H4
c'est un couple j'avais pas du tout en
tête et c'est un coup qui m'a l'air
assez étrange du coup je comprends le
coup qui vient de faire donc comprendre
j'essaye mais je suis pas sûr du tout
[Musique]
donc ok est-ce qu'on est-ce des choses
ailleurs à firu Firo qui place ses
cavaliers petit à petit c'est pas grand
chose ici est-ce qu'on a coupé
je pense pas en rien je pense que les
Noirs vont toujours réussir à sacrifier
leur pièce
mais c'est pas impossible que à un
moment donné un bouquet je dois finir
avec cavalier fou contre
j'arrive à un pion là-haut je me
sacrifie avec une pièce tu vois ça c'est
pas impossible ça arrive mais
alors attends
et le fou qui est bien placé qui prend
les cages jusqu'à valégramment donc
qui est
dominé par ce fou en dessin monstrueux
j'ai encore cavalier c'est 5
pour essayer de pousser
j'aime bien
allez on y va
parce que le pion il va pousser mais dès
que tu pousses ton pion au pire des cas
je peux plus
au pire des cas si jamais j'ai peur et
si vraiment tu arrives à ton cavalier
pour faire un truc comme ça
avant j'aurais besoin de cavalier aussi
et juste je bouge mon fou tu feras d'âme
et je sacrifie mon fou quoi et bon bah
il te restera cavalier fou pour contre
cavalle de pion les Noirs gagne jamais
quoi mais des blancs peuvent peut-être
gagner
en vrai c'est
[Musique]
c'est ça peut être gagnant pour Google
ça serait une bonne nouvelle pour moi
je t’annonce que ma meilleure offre a
fait le coup de clic au hasard encore
une fois qui au hasard qui va être le
viewers du match du stream
clic au hasard qui qui en fait un grand
génie des
prédictions de coûts parce qu'ils
trouvent tous les coups et j'aimerais
secondaire il y a peut-être la prépa
sous les yeux je crois que c'est la
vraie seconde en fait
il a préparé jusqu'au 34e coup la partie
ça va très bien que ça va arriver là
sur échec roi là et chaque j'adore G4
non mais encore une chance il y a une
chance pour les blancs encore parce que
le roi noir il est encore un petit peu
faible mesdames j'aime beaucoup l'idée
parce que je pense que l'idée générale
de Dam B1 c'est pas de faire tour à
champ
je pense que l'idée de dame bien Fatou
et tu pourras jamais faire d'échec et
maintenant si les blancs font rien bah
écoute aussi peut-être que je peux
essayer de la gagner
mais bon après ça reste encore long hein
après même même là genre ok jouer un
coup
juste pour dire
je pense que Tour Eiffel crois là dame
là c'est encore mieux
il est en danger il y a des tarpettes il
a les Noirs au final il joue pour la
nuit et c'est un peu normal que m'avait
dit Rohff avec tes blancs il joue pour
gagner c'est un peu normal donc
tant qu'il a une chance de céder de
gagner et ben il a raison de tenter
voilà prends la diagonale
mais fais attention parce que là il faut
pas se regarder
ça peut être chaud aussi je peux avoir
une dame des 8
faut se méfier de pas absolument vouloir
vouloir gagner et oui
faut pas qu'il prenne trop de risques
je suis pas sûr d'avoir le truc et tu
regardes c'est malinois
un truc quand tu fais chèque tu as pas
ça non plus tu as pas ça ma tour elle
défend tout en fait
elle est pas mal
c'est un coup malin de la part de
chariards
[Musique]
je sais pas où je pars mais si je pars
loin ça me fait peur j'ai pas envie
d'aller trop loin quand même
mais
genre ça ça
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
reste proche ok ça date nul mais une
pression mais ok ça va être nul je pense
qu'on va systématique
Google
ça veut dire qu'il est en forme qui
risque de gagner sa partie
et 45 je pense qu'il va gagner hein
je pense maintenant qu'il a que tu
arrives à jouer H4 j'ai l'impression que
maintenant
on a une cible on sait on se voit
attaquer il a changé les fous d'ailleurs
j'ai bien ce qu'il a fait il a joué
fou prend tour à 5 et maintenant bah
écoute il va se placer pour ces 5 ici je
me place je prends les colonnes et là tu
commences déjà à être un petit peu un
problème de la dame elle a pas beaucoup
de cases
pas venir là ni là
et de partout où je vais aller
et ben il y aura des problèmes
[Musique]
avec ça avec madame qui est active avec
des problèmes donc
je pense qu'à il a vraiment eu la
position qu'il voulait pour mettre la
pression
et bon par contre il est mal au temple
qui joue plus vite Magnus
mais il y a un monde où il peut il peut
la gagner je pense
alors que firou il continue à mettre la
pression
Firo il continue à mettre la pression
ici
parce que
s'il prend
et ben le noir vont rester avec leur
horrible fou ici
donc mon cavalier là il est moche et
quand il arrive en C5 il sera forte
est-ce que tu disais si on peut on peut
se placer sur la bonne case taper sur un
taper sur un peu tout parce que il faut
rester ici c'est pareil c'est un
problème
et le Noir ont aucune envie de donner
leur fou bien sûr donc il y a eu ça dans
le 8 et maintenant il va mettre le
cavalier
qui me rapproche de la case
H6 et si il prend un G4 c'est un peu
comme dans l'autre hein tu me donnes
quand même des
cases quoi ici
non c'est quand même une belle position
pour
[Musique]
la position
mais je suis d'accord
tu étais pas là tout à l'heure je t'ai
fait en plus un bon un petit
commentaire sur toi
ok alors comment ça va se jouer ça
là on peut penser on peut imaginer
que les Noirs vont essayer de pousser le
pion et de sacrifier le cavalier
moi je sacrifié et qu'après il va manger
mon four et je vais pousser ma viande
et donc on peut peut-être commencer
pas ramener le roi et c'est de ramener
les pions voilà j'ai deux un c'est la
partie
moi de l'instant
tout seuls
et c'est lui il passe là-bas ça va être
très long donc il arrive à sacrifier à
mettre son cavalier ici aussi ça prend
trois coups je crois genre ça par
exemple
je fais un truc comme ça
c'est long pendant ce temps là
[Musique]
parce que je vais pas je veux pas que tu
m'attaque
et là bon bah écoute ça ça se calcule
ça fait peur
pour ça qu'en fait en pratique c'est
très très dur pour les Noirs à tenir ça
et le temps le temps te permet pas
forcément
s'il te plaît quoi mais ok bon ça fait
sourire moi ça fait ça m'a fait sourire
quand j'ai vu ça quand j'ai vu assez
tâches 5 ça fait sourire mais ok c'est
pas sérieux quoi
c'est pas sérieux de jouer comme ça
salut voilà rebonjour malin
et on a la partie de ma medirov qui va
se terminer je pense bientôt
[Musique]
je pense comme ça mais si je parle à
haut
raccrocher parce que là c'est chaud
[Musique]
parce que là je peux faire ça je pense
que la
mais en fait
très très bientôt c'est marrant qu'on a
déjà 3h30 de jeu sur une cadence qui
dure à peu près 4 heures et demie on a 0
résultat quoi c'est fou en fait
travailler tout simplement
pour une fois il faut de toute façon
il a fait cavalier 3 filles en G4 et en
fait les parties là il se passe pas
grand chose
je vois pas je sais pas quoi regarder
qu'est-ce qu'on gratte là
[Musique]
on va la voir allez
faire plaisir
[Musique]
ok on va demander à
se terminer le plus tôt
la deuxième qui va se terminer je sais
pas je dirais
[Musique]
en fait pour ça ça va durer ça va durer
45 firou ça va durer gokage ça va
dépendre de ce qui se passe mais ça peut
finir relativement vite ou pas
ça a pas avancer non ça avance pas trop
on va voir
c'est pas forcément plus simple là
Google je suis en train d'essayer de de
[Musique]
voir alors le
piredam on voit qu'il prend bien son
temps mais son temps pour trouver le
plan quoi
on ramène le roi
et une fois que le roi est là
par contre aujourd'hui la fourchette
et là je perds
et maintenant que c'est comme ça les
Noirs ils vont finir par aller mettre
cavalier là ou là
et le classement
et voilà
si gentiment demandé
vous le mettre le classement
vous avez le classement sous les yeux
mais aucun résultat n'est encore
enregistré aujourd'hui donc là c'est la
ronde ça c'était le
c'était
le classement du résultat aujourd'hui
pas de partie fini pour le moment voilà
donc c'est classement pour l'instant
mais elle est partie sont chaudes si on
peut vous faire ce que vous voulez un
truc moi de mon avis je pense que carton
va gagner sa partie
donc ça le propulserait à 9 points sur
18 si c'est le cas qui resterait le
dernier
few je pense qu'il va battre un cas
c'est mon avis ce qu'il a la première
place avec Fabienne
devrait faire nul donc donc 8 et 7 et
avec un départage un média Rohff sauce à
faire nuit sur la partie ça va faire
perpétuelle là on va aller voir et
Aboudou Kawana ça c'est chaud
on va aller voir si tu veux dire erreur
parce que là ça va ça va faire mieux et
s'il y a des choses pour les blancs
quand même route
il y a plus de chance pour les blondes
pour les noirs
H4 il a un peu trop poussé
il a un peu trop poussé pour
vraiment
nul ils vont serrer la main et voilà
serrage de pâte
et la nuit la cordée c'est nul assez
solide en fait c'est une bonne partie de
saut parce qu'en fait dans l'ouverture
je n'avais pas faire de sa peau quand
elle a Mikael en dessin et tout j'aimais
beaucoup beaucoup les blancs
et en fait c'était pas si clair quoi
c'est bien bien abattu et ça fait nul
donc on aura les partages l'Armageddon
j'imagine dans une quinzaine de minutes
ça en vous on vous redira mais ça c'est
nul cette partie donc le premier parti
déjà en tout cas terminé à l'instant la
prochaine partie terminée je pense ça va
être cookeh contre Aniche alors karwana
Abdou on n'a pas vu depuis un moment
aussi
moi la position qui commence un petit
peu à s'ouvrir tout à l'heure on a une
potion très fermée on avait eu autour
des 6
et salut le gardien
salut les gardiens Jedi
j'ai trop apprise cavalier prend il y a
un trou en F5 attention la fourchette
royale oups
et H4 il veut ouvrir la police
[Musique]
je crois que ça m'a assez joli si jamais
il fait roi H6
non voilà je pense à faire ça
je suis français
[Musique]
donc je prends H4 comment on joue ça
ma chute OK
ici pierre pas mal joué hein
je pense que c'est pas la même parce que
mon cavalier se recycle mais là je
t'entends
et est-ce qu'on peut imaginer maintenant
un coup du style cavaillage 6 ou un truc
comme damage 6 pour faire G4 essayer de
d'ouvrir un peu la position et G4 c'est
un coup qui peut faire bien un peu la
structure
sur le long terme
comme ça
faire attention quand même au matelas
tu vois la joie du petit
ça aurait pu être cool d'arriver ici
j'ai pas compris que Madame
il y a plein de trucs ça va pas du tout
ça ne va pas du tout
je préfère les Noirs quand même je
préfère les Noirs même si je vois pas
trop comment progresse
quand même
un essai
intéressant
tu prends je prends et maintenant il y a
lui qui est un peu en prix qui est un
peu en prise
tu manges madame H6 je mange du cavalier
peut-être
il y a du jeu va tout
alors après dame C8
on regarde des petits faiblesses
je pense que les Noirs ont un truc un
petit peu de
jeu légèrement je pense que noir peuvent
un petit peu prendre avant
je pense que ça c'est possible
bon je vois pas trop comment faire mais
je pense que c'est possible
que ça tricote Google
pour l'instant rien de spécial on a taré
et 45 qui se battent
Carson qui essaie d'avoir
un avantage alors là il y a un échange
de pièces qui est proposé alors c'est
quoi un petit peu en arrière
et là 7
et sur B4 tours dessin
je te cloue je défends et je pars
quelle idée
d'en prendre
et sur wife 2 qui est l'autre seul coup
j'ai toujours penser à et je défends
madame comme ça joli
donc en fait tour D8 est la partie
et écoute je menace pour C8 pour celui
qui a une pièce
donc là il faut trouver une solution
monsieur tari
c'est arrivé une solution
quand je bouge le fou peut-être juste
comme ça je sais pas trop où là
au pire j'ai toujours ça ça
et tu vois tu as un petit peu regretté
d'avoir joué au final ton H4 on disait
mais bon
ça reste encore pas clair
mais je pense c'est une position pour
pour bosser
Marius qui a 6 minutes contre 15 minutes
c'est un peu chaud
je pense que ça te dit Fatou on va
rester là dessus je pense
c'est une partie qui peut vraiment
tourner rapidement
parce que les gens n'ont pas trop peu de
temps la pendule six contre 15 minutes
et
[Musique]
et donc là c'est ko on a 33ème coup il y
a encore 7 coups à faire pour avoir un
incrément de 10 secondes par coup ce qui
est rien du tout donc ça va se terminer
en blitz c'est clair
ou tu pousses et ben ça peut vraiment
faire des affaires de Magnus mais pour
l'instant ça m'a venu ce qui est malin
donc
avec inversement de temps je pense que
c'est vraiment très bien pour
Magnus mais là comme il est mal au temps
et si blanc tendin et ben il aurait tout
reprend des un Alicia je te dis merci
cette polygame on va faire est-ce que
vous voulez changer de vie je vais voir
un peu si on les voit mieux avec l'autre
vue j'ai une vue ici c'est
celle là je crois
non c'est pas ça que je voulais mettre
mais pas mal celle-là
ça te dit
pour le gros problème c'est qu'on va
plus Fatou
donc pour les admirateurs de Fatou
après je parle aussi pour l'admirateurs
de Fatou je sais qu'il y en a beaucoup
dans le chat
je pense que les gens préfèrent
on a compris
c'est pour ça que je demande je sais
très bien quand
de profil on peut les avoir en fait j'ai
une autre vue
mais je crois qu'elle est pas terrible
les George rentre voilà ouais les gens
sont pas en cadre du coup c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien
ça c'est quoi celle-là
c'est
c'est la mieux
on regarde ça dans le petit moment
ça te dit tout
pour tenir pour tenir H4 et B4 et ouais
mais tu vois c'est je suis passif
maintenant
c'est le problème c'est le problème de
H4
qui a fait une super partie pendant très
longtemps mais qui finit un peu par
craquer
et
tu vois je pense que c'est aussi un peu
quand on joue contre manuscrit
tu joues un peu pour la nul et au final
tu essaies trop échanger et ça finit par
mal se passer
donc tour de deux c'est la partie
[Musique]
échecs et je commence un peu à grinder
je vois pas encore comment je termine
mais
on sent que les Noirs commencent à
prendre un peu de
un peu
l'avantage là faut trouver un coup pour
les blancs
[Musique]
dans les courants
le mieux c'est pousser le pion c'est de
voir ce qui se passe tu vois une tour ça
vaut 5 points un pion ça va un point
condamné une tour pour faire un petit
pion
c'est généralement pas terrible essayez
de
défendre mieux vos pièces plus armure
harmonieusement
B5 c'est la partie
donc c'est un peu le seul coup
comment est-ce qu'on continue
j'en parlerai chacun qui est possible
j'aime bien par principe de faire ça
dire pourquoi parce qu'en fait quand le
roi est sur la colonne h il est plus
amené à être en problème par rapport au
H4
donc j'aime bien Dame des quatre même si
il y a pas de raison particulière
est-ce que tu penses qu'il peut y avoir
un jour
moi j'ai envie de dire passe ton tour et
par exemple si je fais ça ça
si j'attends en fait tu fais quoi
parce que
la tour si elle quitte la première
rangée j'ai souvent ça sur le foot
si le fou part il y a pas beaucoup de
cases le roi et l'apparence à faire
ça donne pas il y a ça
ça revient là à mon âge je vais finir
par t'attaquer par exemple
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a presque un
exemple possible pour deux jours pas mal
nu
Magnus qui a plus de 4 minutes à la
pendule
24 contre 10
il y a quatre cou à jouer pour avoir un
créneau
donc ça va se terminer en blitz cette
histoire
mais il est quand même en retard donc
c'est pas sûr que soit favorisé
quasiment gagnant je crois que ça fait
nul mais juste une petite seconde on va
voir que Google ça veut dire parce que
je crois que voilà ça va terminer Google
ça ça
et si vous pouvez faire je gagnais
parce que si bouger le roi mais en fait
mais le problème c'est que
les cavaliers
sur ça il prend
j'ai pas d'autre je peux pas faire mieux
donc il va manger le roi
plutôt du coup mon droit c'est 4 à la
place
en fait il y a rien
[Musique]
il faut prendre je peux monter mon roi
pour essayer
peut-être ça
et en fait
dans la position
[Musique]
en fait là
mais sinon les fous ont beaucoup plus de
d'espace
et bien mieux
ok voilà c'est la partie qui se termine
ça va être ça va être nul mais en fait
je regardais avec le petit écran je me
disais franchement
il est pas loin de gagner quoi je vais
remettre la caméra de Magnus
avec la partie de Magnus quand même
mieux
et les Noirs attendent en fait Magnus ce
qui fait il va tomber de ton C2 Magnus
qui fait il veut pas la nul mais je
pense que ce qu'il veut c'est c'est
arrivé au 40e à voir si 10 secondes de
rajout et voir un peu ce qui se passe
les blancs peuvent pas jouer le blanc
aurait rien à faire
juste essayer d'attendre
pour ces deux
pas grand chose à faire chez
Ariane je pense
dans le 4
OK
je vais un petit peu les choses
de jouer
voilà je pense qu'il faut garder les
dames
c'est un super coup
je pense que c'est peut-être le seul
coup
avoir pourquoi est-ce que c'est bon
en fait j'ai pas d'autres coups pas de
cadre madame a pas de casse pour
regarder là ma tour si je la mets en 1
peut-être qu'il y a un problème tactique
peut-être à base d'échec
s aussi
[Musique]
on peut avoir du temps des 6 plus tard
ok je ne sais pas du tout
bon après c'est bizarre
pour le noir alors l'Armageddon a
commencé
on reste ici ou on va voir la magasin
qu'est-ce que j'en pensais
ouais on va demander on va demander aux
gens
où on suit la partie de Magnus avec le
grand fichier cette finale qui est assez
chaude et les gens qui ont peu de temps
la pendule
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
pour rester ici on reste
je suis d'accord
c'est le début oui après de base on
préfère quand même suivre Magnus
mais
je crois que les gens sont juste pour
Magnus donc
on va rester et puis après le manque de
temps ça devient aussi plus intéressant
ouais ouais c'est intéressant de voir
c'est Magnus qui a très peu de temps la
pendule d'ailleurs en plus c'est
quasiment une face CAO là il est à deux
coups d'avoir son rajout de temps donc
il est encore 2 minutes donc oui il va
avoir son rajout de temps donc c'est pas
du Bullet il y a pas star flag
[Musique]
18 il a plus qu'un coup à faire Magnus
d'ailleurs manus qui a arrêté de noter
ses coins
il a le droit de me noter
enfin un joueur peut arrêter de nous
quand il lui reste moins de 5 minutes à
la pendule
même si c'est du de l'incrément
l'incrément permet d'arrêter de jouer à
la porte de noter seulement si ça
m'incrément qui est inférieur à 30
secondes par exemple dans les cadences
normales avec 30 secondes à la pendule
enfin 30 secondes à chaque coup je dois
tout noter c'est la règle c'est comme ça
mais là c'est 10 secondes d'incrément en
40e donc même si un incrément je
pourrais
je sais pas à quel point c'est
intéressant de manger là apparemment
c'est
attention que Ariane qui qui comment ça
va pas mal réfléchir il faudrait qu'il
coupe le vide parce que c'est vrai que
il a une qui peut mettre la pression
chez Magnus mais s'il descend aussi bas
autant que Magnus et ben il risque de se
faire avoir firoun
alors justement Mario
parce qu'il y a moins de 30 secondes à
la fin tu dois rajouter
le règlement dit que quand tu as à la
pendule un rajout de temps de 30
secondes par coup tu dois aller tu dois
tout noter du début à la fin mais là il
y a il y aura 10 secondes d'incrément à
chaque coup donc t'as pas assez pour
jouer noter enfin c'est trop dur quoi
donc règlement dit que tu es pas obligé
je vais le faire plus le fait très bien
mais si tu veux pas le faire tu le fais
pas rien qui passe en dessous et 5
minutes
donc les joueurs qui vont rater ça
appartient en blitz et firoun Akasa fait
nul donc on aura je vais recevoir l'info
sur slack que
21h10 ça sera la le départage de fil
rouge à Nakamura en Armageddon
à partir du moment où il passe en
dessous des 5 minutes il est pas obligé
de noter donc même s'il remonte et même
si avec l'incrément il remonte au dessus
des 5 minutes
à partir de les passer en dessous il a
le droit de piloter du tout
même si tu remontes tu arrêtes enfin tu
remontes pas trop dur de rattraper
c'est ça et
j'avais une autre question c'était quoi
le rajout de temps non non Johan
c'est comme ça
en fait tu notes pas tu tu rattraperas
pas
en plus à ce niveau là enfin de 1 les
joueurs se rappellent des coups qu'ils
ont joué donc pour plus tard
l'ordinateur mais en plus tout est sur
internet donc tu auras besoin là tout va
se terminer tout va se terminer en blitz
quoi
et Ariane qui réfléchit beaucoup là qui
va arriver à hauteur de Magnus et
en direct en blitz ça risque de donner
un avantage pour Magnus quand même
parce que
[Musique]
les Noirs c'est Magnus vous voyez devant
lui les pièces noires
gardent la même couleur qui est logique
furunaka tu gardes la même couleur donc
il est blanc donc il aura les blancs
c'est logique
[Musique]
il reste bookage guéri Abdou Carolina
est-ce que un rapide coup d'oeil le
temps que ouais on peut aller voir alors
gris bon c'est devenu qu'on avait dit
ça va être nul facile et Abdou tu es
celle là Abdou elle est blanc contre
Caravana et
[Musique]
comment un peu plus de mouvement dans
cette partie ouais je pense que Carola
va gagner c'est mon avis tout à l'heure
je pense que le roi est trop faible
les blancs
on va rester sur 45 et puis on
verra après
je garde un œil dessus
et ok en gros j'ai 7 x 4
il y a une pression gamin une pression
de de Magnus
H4 qui a été joué j'arrive pas à
justifier tout à l'heure
j'ai un peu du mal à se dire ça
mais je peux pas encore manger le plomb
pas simple ils sont arrivés au 40e
couche je crois 41 à même hein
maintenant et ben ma venue à 46 secondes
mais il y a 10 secondes d'imprimante
donc c'est pas tout à fait tu vois c'est
pas du cas ou quoi
[Musique]
pas un bon coup alors pourquoi c'est pas
mon couteau va savoir
n'est pas un bon coup à cause de
la finale
tu reprends en H4 qui peut s'avère
gagnante pour les Noirs en plus pas sûr
que ça gagne encore mais
déjà c'est son champion surtout en blitz
ça peut être difficile pour les blancs
de tenir
donc Dame des 6 en plus je me lance
mais ce qui peut être pas mal
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer d'autres
les blancs pas trop en fait le problème
c'est que les blancs à faire après 3
bouches
à la place
oups
désolé thème des 6 je dis rempli parce
que les gens ont plus de temps la
pendule tu vas bien
ici une minute pour les blancs contre 36
secondes pour les noirs et l'incrément
de 10 secondes par coup jouer
dès qu'il va jouer et ben vous allez
voir 10 secondes qui vont s'ajouter dans
leur temps et c'est pour ça qu'en Blitz
c'est plus dur parce qu'en toujours en
blitz et ben tu as moins le temps de
jouer le bon coup et tu puisses d'erreur
il y a je m'en fous
pour ces 5 alarmes aussi oui je suis
d'accord avec quoi ça oui bien sûr
je pensais à je pensais à dames
Adam de 4
peut-être pour ça aussi que tout rond
était pas bon parce que souvent il y a
même des F4 ici
en fait les blancs peuvent pas
attaquer le pion 26 c'est un problème
par exemple plus tout à l'heure ici il y
a une ligne où éventuellement plus tard
pour faire ta F4 d'un prank tout reprend
pour aller manger H4 et j'ai trois j'ai
toujours ton point ici mais sur cet
échange là après tu reprends F4 j'ai
tourné 6 pour manger B6 après tout Rouen
si je fais ça par exemple et ben il y a
plus du tout
aussi à cause de la du mauvais
emplacement de la tour donc c'est pour
ça aussi que la tour elle est mal placée
en E1 et le tour si un ici Dame des 4
attaque H4 ici
et sur H4
un pense un mauvais coup Dame des 4 ans
il y a un gain qui a été raté je crois
ici
c'est pas simple je vois le coup de
l'ordi
du mal à comprendre pourquoi ça gagne ah
oui jolie je ne trouvais je crois que
tout R4 mais 6
un truc comme ça j'ai encore dans ma G3
il y a eu dame Descartes c'est la partie
il y a très peu de temps la pendule 14
secondes chacun
ok je guéri 21h20 l'Armageddon ça a fait
nul
pour ces 6
ouais ça se joue ils ont plus de temps
chacun
la voit la caméra crois H2 et là il y a
des damage de qui peut arriver le roi on
sait pas s'il va s'en sortir
il faut qu'il fasse gaffe Magnus parce
que dans
si ma dame par exemple venait à partir
donc tourner
H2 est un machin
qui a été joué on empêche d'aller 5
instant
et le roi il est un peu en réseau mais
bon elle est toujours des cases vous
voyez il manque de cases ça sent un
petit peu la partie qu'on a eu de saut
contre ma mère
avec le roi de Rohff qui était dans un
courant d'air mais on n'a pas réussi à
gagner alors on est à ce matin
échec et mat
donc il va bien sûr manger là je pense
mais surprise tout reprend je me lasse
mat aussi attention
attention
[Musique]
il y a eu
ça m'a l'air ouf cette position là j'ai
sec là aussi
il y a plus de temps à la pendule
très très chaud cette position
j'ai envie de dire que les blancs mais
est-ce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi échec là je
peux pas venir ici à cause de la tour
échec là-haut
oups je dois rester ici et chaque échec
et chaque échec je vais pas quand je
m'en sors je rêve 5 j'ai dit c'est que
là
je pense qu'au pire des cas je vais
peut-être manger la tour
mais à part trouver
je pense ça fait mieux instant
en tout cas bravo à rien de ta rien qui
va réussir à faire nuit dans cette
position qui était franchement dur à
tenir et en plus qui
rate pas grand chose
on continue avec la dame mais bon ça va
faire nul là il y a plus grand chose à
faire
plus grand chose
en centralise il y a plus d'échec là et
là que V6 ça a l'air nul assez facile
pour Ariane
ça a été le même des quatre
et ça va faire nul normalement
attention on voit la jauge qui qui par
un peu en faveur d'Ariane maintenant
c'est que le pion ici est dur à prendre
des seins qui a été joué
attention au matin ça ça fait peur
il n'y a pas de match je crois je suis
nul non ça fait nul je crois que c'est
nul
ça fait nul il y a pas de il y a pas de
pas moyen de se sauver et ça fait nul
macgus qui est un peu deg qui avait une
position
avec bonne avantage il a pas réussi à
transformer ma venue ce qui
évite de partir on va aller sur d'autres
parties je crois du coup on avait goût
cache qui a fait nul et karwana qui a
battu qui a battu Abdou Fatou pendant
notre absence incroyable elle se fout
tout ce qui se passe j'avais pas du tout
vu mais Caravana a battu Abdou pendant
notre absence et j'avais dit que c'était
dangereux pour les blancs c'était clair
hein cette position était dangereuse
pour les blancs après j'ai 4 attends
c'était où le G4 il y a eu un G4 arrivé
après il y avait plus de temps tous les
deux c'était un blitz
attends on va revenir un petit peu au
moment où il a fait j'ai 4
on avait dit qu'avec j'écarte ça pouvait
être dangereux pour pour les blancs
cette histoire avec le roi qui était
toujours plus faible que que le roi noir
et au final regardez ce qui se passe il
y a plein de mauvais coups c'est normal
ils sont en blitz à la fin il y a plus
de temps mais au final qui est le plus
faible les deux rois sont les deux rois
sont complètement faibles mais c'est
vrai que maintenant H6
et alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait là
il va manger le pion la tour elle est en
prise il a mangé la tour
voilà c'est compliqué là je prends je
prends la haut
et au final
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est pas grand-chose c'était
vraiment le Jake note qui a fait que que
a craqué mais la position était déjà
difficile pour pour les blancs de toute
façon
ils vont commencer donc on avait quoi on
m'a dit quoi il est 21h08 je crois qu'à
21h10 on a 6 roues Naka et à 21h20 on a
goûtes gris et un peu plus tard encore
on aura quinzaine contre Bretagne
donc on va voir si on a la partie de
cette fille ou on a qu'à un qui va se
qui va commencer par un instant
et malheureusement on n'aura pas la vue
qu'on avait avec qu'on avait avec 45 la
vue que j'avais que la caméra c'était
vraiment
vraiment que pour le premier échec pour
la table 1 donc bien sûr Arnaud
on a car voilà qui repasse deuxième
mondial je vous rappelle que
Nakamura avait récupéré la deuxième
place du classement mondial hier en
battant Paris mais là il a fait nul donc
contre contre
les résultats mais avec cette partie et
bien il gagne pas de points lourd tandis
que Caravana qui était je crois 0,3
derrière ça partit donc on passe devant
je peux dire si vous voulez
vous donner les élans exacts des joueurs
oui mais c'est pas fini encore il y a
des
Armageddon oui pour départager le
joueur qui ont fait nul et grâce au
départage il y en a un qui va récupérer
un demi point supplémentaire
donc là il y en a trois qui
on a pris la bonne scène
c'est pas bon c'est la 3 excusez-moi
j'avais pas les caméras
ouais alors karwana 27 86,8
Nakamura 27 83,7
donc trois points
donc c'est vraiment ça se joue pas grand
chose
qui a repris le dessus en élo avec sa
victoire car voilà qualification pas de
nul si partie une nul
incroyable
alors
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
10 minutes
contre 7
et il a l'obligation de gagner avec les
Blancs si il fait match nul et ben il
perdra son Armageddon et à 21h25 on va
avoir
donc c'est cool ça nous laisse le temps
de voir celle-là plus Carson
avec les noirs
et ensuite on aura 21h20 Google je
dirige mais on pourra pas tout suivre
malheureusement donc au cas je dirais on
pourra pas le suivre
et on a tari Garden à 21h25 donc je
pense ça nous laissera le temps de finir
ma caméra à furosa est passé chez tari
Garden
je pense c'est plus important pour nous
de voir de voir aller Raisa quand même
français et après de voir Carlsen plutôt
que de voir que je guéri même si moi
j'aime beaucoup Kesh vous imaginez pas à
ça
c'est une bougie typique des Noirs qui
jouent cette position pour l'attaque en
fait
l'attaque donc c'est des positions qui
sont à 7 tendues vous voyez que le roi
noir est un exposé
hyper exposé mais bon c'est une position
qui reste encore compliqué
et
4G4
F5
ça c'est normal moi j'aime bien sa
position pour les Noirs il y avait une
partie comme ça qui avait été jouée
je crois que c'était Ding avec les noirs
parti avec
le ciel bleu
c'est notre formateur si elle bleu c'est
clairement l'enfant maintenant formateur
Ding
au candidat avec les noirs
et
[Musique]
je sais plus qui regarde dans l'histoire
je crois que Ding a des blancs
ça pouvait être un épaule ou un guerrier
ou un truc comme ça Ding blanc est-ce
que c'est le bleu
de sa victoire ah oui non mais déjà ils
ont avec le championnat du monde ils ont
enchaînés derrière avec un autre tournoi
ils ont fait tous les deux n'importe
quoi
match qui dure un mois à la fin ils ont
plus d'énergie quoi ils sont
alors donc Pierrot qui est en train de
rendre son avantage et laver il avait un
avantage de
de
3 minutes à la pendule et il a déjà
reparle tout son avantage
donc maintenant il faut juste qu'il
vienne la partie avec les Blancs
généralement quand tu as quand tu en as
un magasin
donc l'idée c'est essayer de
utiliser les trois minutes d'avance pour
prendre l'avantage dans la position
pour l'instant
il se fait attraper autant et c'est pas
si clair de 4 il veut ouvrir la position
c'est normal
c'est normal qu'il a envie
la cam plus grand je suis désolé
malheureusement je peux pas j'ai pas
accès à ça
et la seule cam plus grande c'est pour
la table 1 c'est Magnus le reste je peux
pas c'est pas moi qui choisis c'est les
organisateurs et pour cette partie là
j'ai que ces caméras là je suis désolé
je vais voir si j'ai pas mieux mais je
le sais je n'ai pas mieux c'est que ça
j'aimerais bien vous la mettre plus
grande mais malheureusement j'ai pas ce
pouvoir
donc le pion quand il sacrifié et
maintenant il faut
[Musique]
il faut envoyer la
tour je veux ouvrir les
bonsoir mais je veux juste ouvrir la
carte
j'arrive pas à comprendre ta question
genre de paix
pour savoir toi déjà peut-être pas tout
à cette heure là qu'on prend mieux
français que moi j'ai du mal à comment
ta question
quelqu'un dans le monde à
son règne cette même personne a-t-elle
une chance contre
got
j'ai réfléchi
à son top niveau en fait
quand il est au top
c'est vraiment en forme il peut être
difficile mais après les joueurs sont
tellement forts tous que tous peuvent
avoir un bon enfin bonjour en fait ça
dépend des positions et tout mais en
match malus pour l'instant il est quand
même dur à charger sur une partie oui
tout le monde est capable de Magnus mais
sur un match en entier
[Musique]
c'est difficile c'est difficile
mais oui tout le monde je pense est
capable
[Musique]
mais au malice il est quand même il est
quand même de manière générale bien
au-dessus là il est là il fait pas un
bon temps
c'est pas mon tournoi il a pas encore
une seule partie ça arrive
ça arrive mais ça reste quand même le
meilleur joueur
un petit peu
presque des tactiques regarde sur ça
j'aurai ça et ça et malheureusement ça
marche pas parce que tu manges du fou si
je mange
à moins que je fasse ça
rien ne marche
dans le 17
quand tu crois que ça veut dire cher
[Musique]
désolé
je pensais pas non plus qu'on devrait me
traduire un message en français mais il
a mangé ici ah il mange tout ça
qui décide de rentrer là-dedans il a
trois pièces pour deux tours mais la
paire de fou mais ok c'est intéressant
on voit le choix de de filou en pratique
c'est intéressant
il va faire
ce pion ou pas trop vite
j'ai quand même un petit peu de jeu avec
mes pièces
parce que OK
voilà il empêche la tour d'entrer ici
le cavalier aussi qui contrôle la votre
là on a un petit blocus
elle est pas contente
tu défends mais
plus
je pense
il va ramener le roi ici mais bon ça va
être trop trop dur la caille poussée les
tours c'est fort il faut pousser des
pions
la création
et maintenant on pousse
ici sur roi là je pense pas qu'il va
faire 4 je pense pas que ce soit
remboursement intérêt pousser des
vêtements je pense que c'est les pions
genre 5 B4 et pousser créer une majorité
pour C5
je vous rappelle
qu'il va la prendre
c'est marrant en tout cas cette position
c'est pas une question qu'on voit tous
les jours
des fois on voit dame qu'on de tout ou
trois pistolets
c'est marrant
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on voit ce
genre de
on a eu droit F6 de jouer
sur quoi
je pense que les deux pour venir ici moi
parce que il y a plein d'échecs donc je
me dis que bon j'ai vraiment entendu il
peut y avoir quelque chose
une petite fourchette ça peut passer
fourchette
et là il reste une minute 20 pour pour
Ali raisin qui au 40e coup ça veut dire
dans cinq coups va gagner
le droit d'avoir un incrément d'une
seconde parcours ce qui est quasiment
rien déjà en live une seconde parcours
c'est pas grand chose mais alors en vrai
en IRL c'est pire parce que tant qu'on
joue qu'on a pris la pendule la seconde
est déjà quasiment tomber en fait
toi aussi roi H2
OK
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce fou
il jouait
il avance cette fois à venir ici ce qui
empêche le cadeau de venir là
il va manger le pion il est encore fou
des seins
et je peux toujours passer par là par là
et en mettre un peu attention
même prendre
mais il a mangé la regarde
il s'en
foutu lui il va pousser la
mais la raison tout seul
tes pièces sont passives tu as
absolument rien à faire c'est juste fini
quoi
belle partie en tout cas
les raisins rapidement ok je vois c'est
encore en train de jouer
avant de voir Magnus qui va entrer en 7
pour son magasin pour 2 minutes
je vous mets la scène de Google
rattraper
allez on va vite arriver au direct on a
2 minutes avant la partie de
son pari c'était pas ou c'était à les
raisins et
Paris
écoute les blancs avec ce pion passé à
protéger
mais activités comme sur 15 mois
qui se baladent mais les cases blanches
qui sont faibles
le tourage 4 il va les manger ici moi
j'aimais bien aussi le petit coup fou et
fin pour venir en H3 et venir aussi ça
trois quatre
je vais voir en même temps regarde
ça a commencé on va regarder
et je pense que ici c'est bien parti
pour la gagner j'ai l'impression allez
on va sur
carte SCÈNE on part sur la scène et la
partie je vous rappelle que Magnus a les
Noirs enfin vous le voyez je pense à la
caméra
avec la belle caméra
voilà c'est marrant de boire de l'eau en
canette
qui va nous faire ici Paris
et il doit gagner avec les Blancs donc
c'est quand même je pense une bonne
opération de la part de de
Magnus cette position pour l'instant
c'est qu'à valider la voiture
[Musique]
j'ai réussi
alors
on a une position un petit peu qui
ressemble à une fille d'or
non c'est vrai c'est la structure
[Musique]
à rien pour l'instant une position donc
sur un
une position qui peut être pas mal s'il
arrive à ouvrir la position
[Musique]
à parler dans cette position
le fou des deux
parce qu'on sait pas trop le mettre pour
l'instant faut 3 on sait jamais si des
fois il y a du D4 ou quoi que ce soit on
préfère faire la photo je pense
pas forcément une option
c'est simple on échange les fous
bah ça standard tout simple
c'est une position il se passe pas grand
chose pour l'instant
on peut imaginer un tourner un peut être
français
comment est-ce qu'on va continuer
[Musique]
il y a eu j'ai 6 OK
G6 qui veut dire 6 rangée 7 alors j'ai 6
vachement attention quand on le joue
et qui a un cavalier F5 déjà parce que
ça peut faire
de gros problèmes là pour l'instant ça
va ça a l'air d'aller
mais c'est vrai que
j'ai trois
pour proposer un répétition
mais il est vrai que ma venue se joue la
nul en essayant
possible aussi peut-être
non
je crois
échec
c'est la partie
et merci
pour le prime
merci beaucoup pour ton soutien
ah tu prends mon tu me prends mon
cavalier je l'avais pas vu excuse-moi
alors
je pense
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
pas mal aussi effectivement
a été joué en tout cas
par Oriane tari la jauge qui met
un point d'interrogation ici
et alors pourquoi je ne sais pas
mais
ce qui est dur c'est qu'ici les blancs
doivent pour gagner quoi donc je peux
même pas faire les chèques il n'y a rien
quoi
intéressant aussi mais comme tu dis il y
a ça
est-ce que j'ai vraiment envie de faire
ça
[Musique]
parce que au final prise là je prends la
le jeu et je trouve que c'est
intéressant ce qui fait alors Magnus qui
encaisse
pas du tout l'attaque des blancs et en
vrai ben écoutez dommage 5 je sens en
l'air
sur ça il y a ça
comment ça pourrait faire peur quand
même ça fait peur
nous ça fait peur mais
en plus
bon là il faut quand même manger après
il peut aussi manger l'autre cavalier
j'imagine peut-être qu'il y a aussi là
il réfléchit il réfléchit à faire
reprend
prises
et le roi de Magnus est un peu faible
est-ce que tu es obligé de faire ça
est-ce qu'il est pas un coup pour
essayer de défendre le style cavalier 7
c'est embêtant maintenant que la colonne
elle est ouverte c'est embêtant qu'elle
avait acheté ça
il a pris F5
c'est un mauvais coup apparemment
l'ordinateur il y a eu cavalier ou il a
eu pu on prend qui est une erreur encore
à cause de cavalier F4
je pense qu'il a raté ça il y aura Tessa
ici Ariane
F qui s'ouvre
[Musique]
ça a du sens au final
ça a du sens
alors on est comme ça et attention que
deux qui est comment ça va
je regarde s'il y a un résultat chez
Google ça joue encore il y a moyen qu'on
arrive à regarder Google
à te partir alors coca je regarde coca
avait les blancs c'est parti je peux
vous dire un petit peu ce qui se passe
Google est complètement gagnant
ah c'est fini un boom il faut prendre
aka
[Musique]
sur le sur la première partie
tous les deux
ce qui va jouer ici
attention aux contre le jeu
[Musique]
je pense que moi j'ai 8 va être une
menace des Noirs un jour
bon je bouge mon Cavé d'abord mais un
coup comme moi j'ai vite pour essayer de
bouger la tour et d'être actif
là je peux quand même imaginer un coup
de tour mais attention qu'il y a aussi
ça en l'air
donc c'est pas si simple si je bouge mon
cavalier même si je viens là peut-être
ça
et si je prends G2 la
c'est compliqué à retourner
est perdu c'est bien ça Fatou oh là là
elle est perdue elle est perdue la
partie avec
ouais c'est complètement ouf
la personne ou les personnes l'oxyos
continues
nous sommes une grande famille
et là ça va être ça va être perdu alors
comment je mate d'ailleurs elle peut
venir là où là
ils savent ce qui se passe
et il y a quand même un respect tu vois
entre Paris et Magnus ça fait plaisir
quand même de les voir sourire à la fin
et Google qui a fini par gagner la
partie aussi un Google qui a battu un
news guéri donc pour faire un petit si
vous voulez un petit point classement
lors de tournois et c'est parti je vais
vous montrer un petit peu les résultats
ici on a
Ariane tari qui a perdu un à un et demi
contre mec en scène ça veut dire que ils
ont fait match nul
et que m'amuse a remporté l'armée donc
Google qui mène un et demi à un contre
nul et la gare remporté l'Armageddon Ali
Raisa qui perd un magasin contre
Nakamura
auteur d'une super partie qui a battu
aptov lors de la partie classique et
d'ailleurs qui marque trois points
au lieu de Ben un point un point et demi
et le classement après cette sixième
ronde et ben on a toujours en tête et
toujours en tête mais là il creuse un
petit peu le son écart
et cinq points sur le reste c'est
monstrueux
genre en fait je perds de partie
d'affilée en classique je suis encore là
quoi tu vois
je pense que
il a quasiment gagné c'est ouf quoi du
quasiment le double de points de Magnus
c'est un truc de fou quand même
mais bon
il fait un il fait un tournoi juste mon
truc
si vous voulez que je vous donne les
résultats de
Fabienne Cabana dans cette compétition
je vais vous le dire il a commencé par
battre Carsen lui-même
nul contre un esprit il a battu
tari puis fille rousseja avant de perdre
contre ma média Rohff là de gagner
contre les autographes donc c'est quand
même assez monstrueux ça fait 4 et demi
sur 6
contre le top 10 mondial c'est c'est
justement monstrueux d'ailleurs à
l'occasion il gagne 13
points et l'eau 14 points quasiment et
car voilà qui repasse à la deuxième
place
toute la semaine mondiale qui reste
encore bien sûr trois parties 1 et
demain on sera de nouveau accompagner de
Fatou pour pour les commentaires et pour
la fin de tournoi donc Fatou je dois il
fait nuit
on doit presque plus dans la pédons
donc voilà sur ce je pense qu'on va on
va vous on va vous laisser
comment salut à T'choupi il arrive au
meilleur moment qui arrive au moment où
on arrête le stream donc salut à toi et
demain essaie d'arriver plus tôt et
numéro 1 c'est qui va numéro 1 c'est
Magnus bien évidemment donc demain on
reviendra avec Fatou sur les coups de
17h pour pour la 7e journée de la
compétition donc on a 9 rondins donc on
sera là jusqu'à vendredi je vous
rappelle que mercredi on aura la joie de
repos
donc demain c'est
mercredi repos et on revient jeudi et
vendredi donc merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir accompagné
merci une excellente soirée ou nuit à
toutes et à tous yes excellente soirée à
tous et puis et puis reposez-vous bien
parce que demain nous sommes de retour
et vous nous supporterez pendant
j'imagine tout ta soirée comme vous le
faites depuis maintenant plus d'une
semaine donc merci à tous passez une
bonne soirée
bonne soirée à toi Fatou à bientôt et
à bientôt Ciao